hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
this is one of our regular AMA ask me
anything episodes which used to be
bonuses but due to increased
responsibilities various sorts these are
now counting as regular Monday episodes
uh those responsibilities of course
being my new job at Johns Hopkins where
I am reporting from right now or at
least I'm reporting from Baltimore we
have just moved Jennifer and I we're in
our temporary little digs here in an
apartment building so it's not quite the
smooth ready to go setup that I had back
in LA in terms of recording the podcast
hopefully this will all go good but if
uh there are noises or whatever that are
unpredictable that's just the kind of
thing that we have to deal with in life
anyway I don't want to really dwell on
that because I have a big fun
announcement for mindscape listeners
it's fun for me anyway I'm very excited
we are going to be sponsoring a
scholarship for college students or at
least one student hopefully the idea is
uh with the organization called bold
b-o-l-d bold.org is an organization that
helps people sponsor scholarships for
college students and so they reached out
and basically proposed that the
mindscape community can contribute to
sending someone to college or at least
uh partly defraying the cost of going to
college not all the costs sadly we know
the cost of going to college these days
are a little bit extreme but we're
looking to raise ten thousand dollars or
more and it's going to be easier than
that sounds because I'm going to match
the first five thousand dollars what
that means is if we get five thousand
dollars of other people donating I will
match up to that to make it ten thousand
dollars total and if we go beyond that
that's great I will stop matching
because I will run out of money but we
can raise as much as we can and ten
thousand dollars will go to a deserving
student and the next ten thousand
dollars will go to another deserving
student Etc it's certainly not enough to
pay for college but maybe it's enough to
help someone out and the name of the
scholarship is the mindscape big picture
scholarship of course I've written a
book called the big picture but it's not
about the book it's about trying to
understand the world at the biggest
picture level of resolution trying to
understand the fundamental nature of
reality so the scholarship will go to
people who want to do that who want to
go to college and whether it's physics
or philosophy or studying the origin of
life or Neuroscience or the nature of
morality or whatever it is people who
want to really think about these big
questions and especially what I'm
interested in doing is helping people
who might not otherwise be able to do
this so I'm looking for people who are
in groups that are underrepresented in
these various Fields physics philosophy
Etc and also first generation students
you know what I have in mind with this
is someone who isn't that familiar with
what it means to go to college
especially in these areas and they might
think you know maybe I should do
something more practical right maybe I
should do something that helps earn a
living down the road which is a fine
thing to do nothing wrong with that but
maybe in the back of their minds there's
someone out there who's thinking you
know but what I really am passionate
about is studying these abstracts not
very practical questions about the
nature of things the beginning of the
universe what it all means that kind of
stuff so what I hope to do with this
scholarship is help them out to give
that extra little nudge that maybe can
change someone's life by enabling them
to pursue uh that thing that they're
passionate about so if you're interested
in contributing everyone is invited to
contribute you don't need even to be a
mindscape listener but that's the
primary set of targets you go to https
colon slash
bold.org funds slash mindscape so that's
bold
bold.org funds fu 2nds slash mindscape
and you can donate money there it's 100
tax deductible and 100 of it well I mean
you don't get 100 of it back would you
deduct it from your taxes but you can
deduct it as a charitable deduction uh
if you pay enough taxes to do that what
I meant to say was a hundred percent of
your donation goes to the scholarship
recipient so bold does not take any
fraction of your donation out they
support their own administrative efforts
Etc through a different set of donations
you can donate to bold to keep them
going but when you donate to the
mindscape big picture scholarship your
money will be going to the recipient and
bold.org will sift through the
applications to make a long list of
possibilities and then I will sift
through those to decide who's going to
get it so certainly I hope we can get
the 10K to offer one scholarship this
year you know it's a way that I do make
some money off the podcast and that's
good because I like money and it's great
but I do also want to give back uh this
is a community I think of not just me
and not even just the guests on the
podcast but the listeners as well
a community that really feels the
importance of asking these questions
that are not you know the immediate
interests of politics or culture in the
world right now but something that is a
little bit longer lasting a little bit
more uh Eternal in these this nature of
questions and I want to support people
who want to do that from a young age and
who knows what they might grow up to do
great things maybe future mindscape
guests we don't know anyway uh so thanks
for listening to that sales pitch I
think this is a good way for me and us
to give back for me in particular to
give back for some of the money that I
do get from the podcast doing a little
bit of good for the world hopefully so
that's bold.org funds slash mindscape
very very exciting I'll keep you updated
on how that goes uh and with that we'll
dive into the AMA for those of you
remarkably who've not been here before
this is the monthly episode where I
answer questions from patreon supporters
so the questions are asked by people who
uh support mindscape on patreon
different URL there that's patreon.com
Sean M Carroll uh you can support
mindscape with a dollar per episode or
whatever it is and then if you do that
every month you can ask questions
um I don't get all the questions there's
too many of them I go for ones that I
have interesting things to say about uh
ones that are shorter ones that I
haven't answered before and so on so uh
with that let's go
oh
[Music]
so our first question is from Edward
Morris who says in your discussion with
Ed young about animal sensation I notice
you never use the word qualia is this
because you consider the whole concept
of qualia including questions like
whether one organism's color spectrum
might be inverted relative to another's
inherently nonsensical in a poetic
naturalist understanding of
Consciousness or with the language of
quality of be something like the
language of free will a legitimate way
of referring to a concept that emerges
in higher level descriptions of
Consciousness so you're right actually
I'm kind of reluctant to use the word
qualia I'm not even sure I could Define
it exactly but quality is the word that
philosophers sometimes throw around to
think to
characterize the experiences that we
have right so there's the fact that
you're seeing the color red which can be
explained physiologically in terms of
wavelengths of light and firings of
neurons but then there's the experience
of the redness of red and that is what
is supposed to be a qualia I don't even
is quality only plural I don't even know
again I don't use the word very much and
the reason why I don't use the word is
because it seems to be a little bit
slippery like I get what people are
going for but sometimes you will hear
the word used in a way that makes it
implied that it can't possibly be a
purely physical thing other times you
will hear it word used in a way that
doesn't imply that right so I think that
the definition or the use of the word
qualia is a little bit ambiguous as to
whether it is supposed to represent
something that is by definition
non-physical and that's why I don't like
to use it because it's just a vague word
right it just refers to different things
when different people use it so also of
course I am a little bit skeptical about
how much we know or could reasonably say
about questions like as Edward says
whether one organism's color spectrum
might be inverted relative to another's
so I don't know what that means honestly
like in what does inverted mean so
presumably that means something like
when one person is seeing blue or one
organism is seeing blue the other is
seeing red and vice versa but I don't
know what that means because I don't
think there's any objective
meaningfulness to saying I'm seeing red
other than the fact that I'm seeing
those wavelengths of light corresponding
to red so I don't know what it could
possibly mean to be in a color spectrum
being inverted so basically these words
open up
um some connotations that I'm not really
happy with they're not very precise a
little bit vague so of course if you
want to use the word and Define it
precisely then that's fine but in the
context of the conversation with Ed I
didn't really want to take time to do
that
I do believe there is an experience of
seeing things and you can give it
whatever name you want
Rob Petro says you've previously done
several episodes on representative
government democracy and how these
things come to an end given the recent
devastating Supreme Court rulings on
overturning Roe v Wade stripping states
of the rights to impose reasonable gun
laws preventing judicial review of
partisan gerrymandering Etc what do you
see as the likelihood that we are
already in a failed democracy and if not
just fully realized it yet if not what
actions can we really take to address
this decline apart from voting as the
persistent attacks on voting rights and
fair local election rules seem targeted
to minimize the efficacy of this most
direct and fundamental response so yeah
there's two questions here but I'm going
to group them together because this is
something that we should be keep talking
about I think we're not we're not
finished discussing these issues they're
very much ongoing and they're both big
picture issues like we talked about in
the intro but also of the moment
politically and that's that's fine
that's fair game so no I don't think
that it's right to say that we're
already in a field of democracy you know
what I really think is that these things
are unpredictable you know I think that
human beings congregated together to
make societies to make democracies are
hard to predict exactly what's going to
happen and then you know this is part of
the idea behind the physics of democracy
project it's because unlike in Isaac
asimov's psycho history in his
foundation series where he said if you
get enough people together their
idiosyncrasies will average out and you
can exactly predict what's going to
happen I think he was wrong about that
because you do get a bunch of people
together and there is collective
Behavior but even the individual people
are complex systems it's not the same as
getting atoms and molecules together to
make a fluid or a gas in that case the
the Dynamics of the atoms and molecules
are sufficiently simple that you can
average over everything and get more or
less predictable deterministic behavior
on the macro scale but when your
Collective phenomenon comes from a bunch
of people who are themselves pretty darn
complex than that averaging just doesn't
work and so what you can do instead is
talk about the probabilities uh that
what the possibilities I guess as well
as the probabilities is it possible that
we are that our democracy is failing I
don't think it's failed and again let's
pause to point out that some people just
want to be you know cheaply cynical and
say well we're not a democracy because
some people have more power than others
or you know my vote doesn't count or
whatever fine okay I mean that's a point
you're trying to make it's not the point
we're talking about right now what we're
talking about the real difference
between the ability to vote at all the
ability to have elections where there
are multiple parties and you're not sure
who's going to win versus systems where
it's clear who's going to win all the
time because there is only one party or
there's not parties at all there's just
an autocratic ruler okay that's the
distinction we're talking about right
here right now by those lights we are a
democracy okay and again there's another
bunch of people who want to be nitpicky
about a republic versus a democracy we
are a Democratic Republic which is both
the Republic and a democracy that is the
correct way of thinking about it so
anyway those caveats aside
um we're a democracy right now but
there's no reason to think that we will
be forever democracies fail the Roman
Republic lasted for 500 years which is
hugely long right now it depends on how
you count but by some ways of counting
the United States with its Constitution
is the longest
persistent
existing Democratic Republic in the
world
there's some footnotes there also
because depending on who how you count
you know there's some subsets of
countries that are ruled over other
countries but they vote et cetera et
cetera but you know big established
clear-cut countries that have been
having a democratic system the United
States is the longest existing one right
now and it's not that long right two and
a half centuries maybe uh less than that
if you just counting the Constitution so
um but it's it's still pretty long
compared to a generation right compared
to the lifespan of a person so there's
no rule that says we have to last for
another two and a half centuries we
could last for another two and a half
years you know we just don't know and
that's not to say because we don't know
anything goes we can certainly pinpoint
probabilities we could have credences
that the Democracy that we have right
now is going to last and it won't and
you know I don't like to be an alarmist
about these things because I think that
people like to get attention by being
alarmist and talking about all the
dangers but this is a danger I think is
super duper real and this is one of the
reasons why on the podcast uh I try to
talk about it every so often even though
it's not you know one of the top two
topics that we talk about here
um I do want to keep reminding people
about this fragility you know we're a
complex system there can be bifurcations
phase transitions there can be sudden
shifts caused by tiny changes in the
individual states of every person right
if every single person moves a little
bit in an anti-democratic Direction by
just a little bit that has a huge impact
on the likelihood that democracy Will
Survive and I think that there's there
are many complications here you know
I've talked directly about democracy but
also about polarization with people like
will Wilkinson and Ezra Klein we talk
about democracy with people like Astrid
Taylor and David to Savage and uh and
Edward Watts who talked about the
decline of the Roman Republic
um
and it's a complicated thing because
it's not just an you know you vote and
the majority wins right that's not the
system we're in and that would be a bad
system I don't think the direct
democracy is is very fruitful uh to
explore in this modern world because
things are too complicated you need
Representatives who even if they
themselves are not experts their job is
to talk to The Experts and figure out
what to do that's I think that's a
better system than just letting
everybody vote on everything but what it
means is that there's all sorts of
mechanisms by which a minority of people
can basically take over the country
right uh the Supreme Court the Electoral
College the Senate of the United States
Congress these are all institutions
which wield an enormous amount of power
and are something other than let's just
let the majority have its way and that's
there's a reason for that you know the
the people who wrote the Constitution in
the first place did it for a reason
um they wanted to protect the rights of
my minorities but there's two things
that are happening here it's good to
protect the rights of minorities but
number one the differences in
representation difference in population
in different states of the US now is
enormously larger than it used to be so
the slight malapportionment that you get
by giving each state the same number of
Senators wasn't a big problem back in
the 1790s it's a much bigger issue now
and the second problem is that you have
to distinguish between protecting
minority rights and allowing minority
rule so the obvious instability of a
setup like ours is if the mechanisms
that have been put in place to make sure
the minority has a voice are hijacked by
the minority to take power and keep it
if you can put mechanisms in place that
prevent a majority from electing the
people they're trying to elect and that
can be a self-sustaining problem for
your purported democracy and I think
this is I mean you don't need to be very
you know aware of current events to know
this is a very very real problem a very
real Prospect this is going to happen
because it's not a secret you see the
plans being laid out in front of us they
tried in the 2020 election they're going
to try again in 2022 2024
Etc
um and you know not every Republican
wants to do this but plenty do you can
look at the polls right and you can look
at the plans that are just being
discussed right out there in the open
you can look at what the
States themselves are doing I mean
basically for those of you who are not
Americans
the the issue is that we have an
electoral college so States the 50
states of the U.S elect a certain number
of people who then vote to see who's
President and roughly speaking that is
almost supposed to be representative
because unlike the U.S Senate where
every state gets two senators the
Electoral College bigger States get more
electors the reason why it's not
completely representative is because
usually the states allocate their
Electoral College members
uh winner take all so a big state that
just goes 51 for one person and 49 for
the other all of their electoral votes
go for one person so it's a kind of
mixed up system for that reason uh but
again there were reasons to do it the
problem is
you're supposed to in the modern system
this is not the original system but in
the modern system you're supposed to
just allocate those electors on the
basis of the people who voted in your
state and what's happening right now is
that states are putting in systems which
let the state legislature overrun
overrule the vote of the actual people
so you could have a big state which
voted for one person rather than the
other and the state legislature just
says no we're not going to send those
electors to the Electoral College this
is the explicit plan being put in in uh
place right now and the cover for it
would be well we don't believe the vote
totals because we think you're cheating
there's been essentially zero evidence
that anyone is cheating there's voter
fraud on anything like that but that is
the rhetoric that is used to justify
throwing out the actual results of the
election
and you know we're in a polarized pretty
evenly split country so a tiny amount of
this can go a long way it's not
completely absurd to think that one
person could win the popular and
electoral vote by a lot in 2024 and yet
Shenanigans at the state level could end
up with the other person being elected
president and that person then gets to
pick more Supreme Court Justices and
more local officials will you know come
into power because of this and so there
is a positive feedback mechanism that
pushes us away from truly Democratic
representation this is a real huge
enormous problem and the other question
that Rob asks is what do we do about it
um yeah I mean I wish I knew I think
there's other there's another question
down here that is related to that and
um
you know of course there's the
simplistic thing you know vote get your
friends to vote whatever but exactly
because of the system that we have the
people who are most worried about the
dangers to democracy are those whose
votes don't matter that much because
they're probably living in states where
the election is very one-sided for one
side or the other right it's a small
number of states that can possibly have
this uh crucial impact and this is why
by the way I know I'm rambling on about
this but it's just really really
important
um and I don't I feel a little bit
powerless I don't know what to do about
it but
the there's of course been a push
against the Electoral College for
exactly this reason because it's been
several times in the past few elections
that the person with fewer popular votes
has won the Electoral College and
because the United States is more or
less at the current moment a law-abiding
institutional government
um we have given the election to the
person who has won fewer electoral votes
George W bush than Donald Trump
um we listen to the rules okay
um and so but the rules are dumb the
rules don't work anymore they don't
apply to the conditions that originally
made people want to put these rules in
place no longer apply so we should be
protecting minority rights the rights of
states that have smaller numbers of
Voters Etc
but we can do it in a much better way
than this and so some people are saying
look just get rid of the Electoral
College I think that makes perfect sense
honestly there's no reason why the
President should be elected by this
weird Baroque kind of Rube Goldberg
system and there's a very dumb counter
argument that says oh if you get rid of
the Electoral College then small states
will be ignored because you'll just want
to win the most votes in the popular
votes you'll spend all your time in New
York and California and Texas and you'll
ignore all the small states that is an
entirely bogus argument because you're
comparing it to the current system with
the Electoral College and in the current
system any state whether it's Republican
or Democrat big or small Urban or rural
any state where it's more or less clear
which candidate is going to win gets
completely ignored in the election so no
one is out there in the presidential
election campaigning in Wyoming and
Montana they're small states population
wise they're large in terms of square
footage but no one's going to campaign
there because they're going to vote for
the Republican every time so why bother
campaigning there and also why bother
campaigning in New York or California
where uh they're going to vote
Democratic almost every time that's a
recent phenomenon but in in the current
situation that's what's going to happen
in the in a direct popular vote for the
president there will be equal reasons to
campaign everywhere you know up to the
fact that you can sort of reach more
people in a big city but these days most
of the campaigning is not done by
literal rallies that's not how you reach
most of the people you have ad buys and
uh commercials and so forth and those
would go into places they don't go now
if you got rid of the electoral college
so I think there's no reason to keep the
electoral college right now but there's
also no
institutional will to get rid of it and
you know the one so anyway what can you
do about it I mean you can vote and you
really can vote there's other people are
saying well we've been voting it hasn't
worked well vote more have other people
vote more that's the most obvious direct
thing you can do uh number two you can
help persuade other people right and and
this is something where I'm not an
expert but there are experts out there
how do you persuade other people how do
you actually get people to your side and
you don't go you don't immediately go
for the people who are way far on the
other side okay like that is a lost
cause on people on either side of any
highly polarized debate are not the
persuadable ones but there's always huge
numbers of people in the middle those
are the ones you should be thinking
about reaching and so how do you reach
them it's not haranguing them and
telling them they're stupid all right
that's not how to do it you have to be
persuasive and you have to be friendly
and you have to present the case that
people like you are probably on the
right side okay that's a difficult thing
to do there are techniques that have
been uh developed for doing that study
up on those and and try try to learn
them and the other is even if you live
in a state which is very much on one
side or the other you can still maybe
influence your actual representatives in
Congress or the state legislature or
whatever by asking them to do something
you know like I will vote for Democrats
compared to Republicans right now when I
was younger I would vote either way
because I don't actually want to be a
starkly ideological about these things
but the modern U.S Republican party is
just an embarrassing disaster and I
cannot imagine voting for it right now
most of the people don't even believe
that the election was fair which is
complete crazy nonsense so it's clear
that I'm voting Democrat in the
immediate future but what you can be
just be legitimately disappointed about
is that our Democratic representative uh
Representatives don't take this problem
nearly seriously enough see they they're
not really nearly as worried about the
decline of democracy as they should be
they sometimes give it lip service but
you know if you've been in this business
a long time there's a tendency to treat
everything as business as usual and
that's a huge problem because this is
not business as usual okay this is not
typical partisan infighting this is not
just everyday politics this is an
existential threat to our system of
government and because it is so unique
and so dramatic it calls for unique and
dramatic responses and we have not been
getting those even from the people
nominally on our side for those of us
who are Democrats so even if you're in a
deep blue State Etc you can still try to
put pressure on the people who are
democratic representatives to say like
look take this problem seriously do it
by writing to them by emailing them by
visiting them it's actually easier than
you think to like visit Washington DC or
your local Congressional office and at
least talk to a staffer if not to talk
to a
a person the actual representative or
Senator or whatever but sometimes you
can even do that so try to do all those
things
um I don't know if it's going to help
you know but uh taking the problem
seriously and really thinking about what
to do about it is a major First Step
which a lot of people don't even do as
much as they should anyway sorry for
that very long thing but I could go on
maybe this should be a solo episode but
I think I said most of the important
things I want to say
Peter blankenheim says
just to change topics here a little bit
uh the Babar group at the Stanford
linear accelerator recently observed
that the B mesons oscillation to its
anti-particle takes less time than the
reverse oscillation violating T symmetry
t for time
when that got called an arrow of time
you objected saying that the arrow of
time comes from the low entropy of the
big bang and said indeed the entire
phenomenon of T violation has absolutely
nothing to do with the era of time but
wait a reaction that is faster than its
reverse is pretty special why doesn't
that qualify as an arrow of time well
it's pretty special it's certainly very
interesting so I don't know how recently
this was in my recollection the thing
you're referring to was a few years ago
but yeah we know that there is a
symmetry or at least a transformation in
particle physics in Quantum field Theory
called T capital T time reversal
symmetry okay and we know that this is
violated in the standard model particle
physics we've known that for a long time
uh We've sort of known it indirectly and
the recent experiments have been seeing
it directly okay so that's the
Improvement but no one is surprised
about this recent finding it's just a
little bit more direct than we had
before
but it's not narrow of time and the
reason why is because it's perfectly
reversible and so this is a subtlety and
actually I will talk about this in um
the book coming out in September the
biggest ideas in the universe volume one
because this issue of reversibility
versus an arrow of time is a very subtle
but an important one the thing about the
arrow of time what we usually call the
arrow I mean again you're welcome to use
the phrase Arrow of time however you
want it's free country but what we mean
generally in physics and philosophy by
the arrow of time is an irreversibility
of things it's not that there's a
different rate of things going One
Direction or another but things only go
in One Direction okay entropy increases
and of course at the very small scale
where entropy is not very well defined
it can fluctuate up and down but in the
macro World ice cubes melt in warm
glasses of water but glasses of water
not spontaneously form ice cubes and hot
water in them okay and the point about t
violation is that it is a little bit of
a definitional issue going on here it's
a little bit less solid than you might
think from usual particle physics
discussions what do you mean by T
violation right you know so you say uh
Peter in the question
um a reaction that is faster than its
reverse is pretty special sure but what
do you mean by the reverse okay so that
t symmetry or that t transformation has
to be defined very specifically what
gets reversed think about classical
mechanics okay think about a system of
objects particles with positions and
momenta and you say okay that's it's
just perfectly classical it's perfectly
time reversal symmetric right we all
agree but what do you mean by time
reversal you take the system at its
initial State you evolve It Forward in
time and then you reverse it backwards
and it comes back to where it is but
what do you mean by that reversing
backwards so the answer is you need to
both
take the you need to take T to minus t
okay you need to take time to minus
times you literally run it backwards but
also if you've taken the system evolved
It Forward before you go t to minus t to
reverse it you need to flip the sign of
all the momenta of the particles okay
every particle has a velocity mass times
velocity is momentum and you have to
reverse the direction of that momentum
because otherwise it's going to just
keep moving in the same direction it
went in and it's not going to reverse at
all okay and this seems very innocent I
flip the momentum to minus the momentum
what else could I do really momentum is
mass times velocity velocity is
derivative respect to time it's going to
flip but it's a little bit of a
important move there because when you
get to other kinds of systems like
systems and Quantum field Theory there's
no momentum variable right there's a
wave function and so what exactly do you
do to the wave function to flip it to
reverse it and then evolve it backward
in time
and so particle physicist Quantum field
theorists have invented a procedure that
flips the sign the time reverses the
sign of the wave functions you can
evolve it backwards but there's a little
bit of arbitrariness involved in that
procedure and so
in particular in particle physics there
are also Transformations called C and P
right charge conjugation which is
flipping particles with anti-particles
and parity which flips space as well as
time and we know that even though T is
violated and C is violated and P is
violated the combination CPT is
preserved so if you take a system evolve
it quantum mechanical system evolve It
Forward in time and then for a little
bit and then you stop it and you reverse
not only the time Direction but also the
space directions and the particles to
anti-particles and then run it backwards
you get to exactly where you started
okay that's CPT symmetry but here's the
thing I could just Define what I mean by
time reversal as what most people call
CPT no one can stop me from doing that
and you can again you're free to Define
it however you want but there are the
important non-trivial physical fact is
that there is a Time reversal operation
that is perfectly preserved by the laws
of nature and we just happen to choose
to call that CPT rather than calling it
t but it is a reflection of the
underlying reversibility of the
fundamental laws and that is why it is
not an arrow of time because every place
that you go to from an initial starting
position can be reversed exactly to
where you started without any loss of
information or ambiguity you can't do
that in the macroscopic world if you see
a glass of water you don't know whether
10 minutes ago it had an ice cube in it
that melted or not it is irreversible so
that's the important physical difference
between these T symmetry violations in
particle physics and a real honest to
goodness Arrow of time
all right I'm going to group two
questions together one is from Lima I
think is the pronunciation who says I've
been wanting to ask for a while what
your actual take on Stephen wolfram's
hypergraph project is and Brandon Lewis
says I see a lot of overlap between how
you describe quantum gravity in your
early episode on the topic and Stephen
wolfram's graph theoretical approach to
fundamental physics you know I was left
with the impression that you don't find
wolfram's approach all that compelling
could you expand a bit more on this
topic so yeah so both are asking what I
think about Stephen wolfram's project
you know I'm not being Coy I'm not
trying to hide my uh opinion about this
I think that I said it in the intro to
that episode when I had uh Stephen on
and so two things are my reaction to it
one is I'm very glad he's doing it I'm
very glad the people are trying out of
the box uh unconventional approaches to
fundamental physics I do think that
there is a bit too much
conventionality in how we approach these
very difficult problems I think that we
need more variety in our approaches and
that's easy to say
but in practice what everyone means when
they say yes we need more variety in our
approaches is we need more uh approval
for my Approach we need more support for
what I'm trying to do it's very hard to
support research for an approach in
fundamental physics that you personally
don't approve of you don't think it's
very likely to succeed but you are going
to prove doing it just because we should
be doing different approaches so I
really think we should try to do that
anyway and that's what I try to do so I
I don't think that wolfram's project has
a great chance of success but I do think
that it's worth supporting for that
reason why the second thing is why don't
I think it's a great chance of success
you know
I think that there's basically two
possibilities you know what I'm doing
and what other people are doing uh and
trying to understand fundamental physics
more deeply is trying to understand
quantum mechanics more deeply quantum
mechanics is a framework not just a
specific Theory so all the successful
theories of nature that we know of right
now are within this quantum mechanical
framework we have zero evidence or
intellectual reason to move Beyond
quantum mechanics we should still think
about what that would mean to do so just
so we can test it Etc but there's no
evidence either empirically or even
theoretically that says the quantum
mechanics is wrong okay and furthermore
I would argue that we haven't tried
nearly as hard as we could to work out
what fundamental physics should be like
using conventional quantum mechanics
that's what I and my collaborators are
trying to do so I think that when you
have a
program that starts from something other
than conventional quantum mechanics
which is what wolfram's project does
there are two possibilities one is what
he will find is that they just
ReDiscover quantum mechanics in which
case great but I already knew quantum
mechanics and therefore I'm working on
that directly I'm you know using that
hint that nature has given us that this
is the way things work or alternatively
they will not discover quantum mechanics
they will discover that their theory is
different than quantum mechanics which
would be great but then probably it's
not going to work because quantum
mechanics is super duper successful of
course there's a third option that it's
different than quantum mechanics and it
does work and that would be hugely
important and really really interesting
so that's why they should keep trying to
do it but I'm not going to put a lot of
money on doing that and you know the
other reason why putting money on it
seems Seems ill-advised to me is that
it's hard to make progress in
fundamental physics it's hard to really
come up with an important insight about
how nature works at the most fundamental
level and historically the way that
we've made really really important leaps
of understanding is that we've been
nudged in the right direction by data
right by empirical information that the
world has given us uh I forget who
originated the idea but Sydney Coleman
my old Quantum field Theory Professor
certainly like to say that you know
hundreds of philosophers could not have
gotten together and invented quantum
mechanics before the 20th century you
know classical mechanics are just
working very well and no one would have
had the idea of coming up with quantum
mechanics until the data forced us into
it so even though it might turn out to
be the case that we need bigger Bolder
ideas and fundamental physics the idea
that we're just gonna guess the right
one and then work it out and it's all
going to work just seems very unlikely
to me it could have happen so that's why
I wanted it to be uh explored but I'm
not going to spend my time exploring it
because I you know my life is too short
I need to work on things that I think
are a little bit more likely to
eventually succeed
okay Paul Hess says
thank you for the solo episode number
200 on the cause the philosophy of the
Multiverse
in that episode you mentioned that if
the cosmological constant stays constant
the universe would expand into something
approaching to sitter space you then
describe this as a nearly perfect black
body with a defined temperature that
lasts for an infinite time why should
the universe ever stop expanding or
cooling why would it remain in any
stable state with any defined
temperature instead of continually
expanding and cooling good this is a
very straightforward uh question about
the quantum nature of decider space
which is which is fine you know I
probably just glossed over that a little
bit too quickly in the solo episode and
because it is a you know tricky
interesting subtle feature of the
interplay of general relativity or
classical theory of space-time and
Quantum field Theory you know even if we
don't have a full theory of quantum
gravity yet we do know a lot about what
we think of as Quantum field theory in
curved space time so the idea the
framework in which we treat space time
is purely classical then we do Quantum
field theory on top of that okay Quantum
filtering curve space time so we're not
quantizing the gravitational field
itself we're quantizing everything else
and this is not supposed to be a good
theory of everything it's supposed to be
an approximation to what the full
correct theory of quantum space time is
actually like in that approach you can
ask about Quantum fields in decider
space
and again you know general relativity
itself even classical general relativity
without any Quantum Fields there's a lot
of subtleties about words like expanding
okay is the sitter space expanding or
not so decider space was the very first
um sorry that's not actually true uh the
history is that Einstein invented
cosmology modern cosmology by imagining
the universe was completely smooth in
every direction plugging into his
equations and finding that the Universe
had to either expand or contract and he
didn't think that's what the universe
was doing there was no empirical
evidence that the Universe was expanding
or Contracting so he put in the
cosmological constant to balance it and
keep it stationary and then what
desitter did Willem desitter Dutch
astrophysicist was to say okay what
Einstein did was put in matter plus the
cosmological constant and balance them
what if we just remove the cosmological
constant sorry I got it exactly wrong
what if we just remove the matter have
nothing but the cosmological constant
and he found an exact solution to
Einstein equation and has happened many
times in the history of gr Einstein
himself was perturbed by this he didn't
believe it he didn't like it but he
eventually uh came to to sit her aside
and he and the sitter actually worked
together to invent another solution but
anyway the decider solution has nothing
but cosmological constant so it turns
out as a subtlety of general relativity
that you can take this space-time
four-dimensional decider space nothing
in it but vacuum energy but the
cosmological constant and you can slice
it in different ways by slice we mean
it's a space time you can think of it as
space plus time separately so the
slicing is slicing the space time into
moments of constant time uh that we call
space at any One Moment In Time
in good old ordinary flat space time is
more or less an obvious way to do that
we all agree what space and time look
like in the sitter space it's not
obvious there are different ways to
slice it some ways of slicing to
sitter's base make it look like it's
expanding
other ways of slicing to Center space
make it look like it's not expanding
like it is in fact stationary
it's a complicated thing it's a subtle
thing and you really gotta dig into the
details of the mathematics of general
relativity to understand what is going
on there but the point is I'm just
pointing the ambiguity of thinking of
the sitter space as expanding when you
have matter in the universe as well as
the cosmological constant then there's
an obvious natural way to slice the
universe into space and time namely
slice it so that on each slice the
density of matter is more or less
uniform
so over time the density matter will go
down in an expanding Universe it will
increase in a collapsing universe but
across space at any one moment the
uniform the density is more or less
uniform okay so then you can say well
what I mean by expanding is in those
slices the density is going down the
space is expanding but when there's no
matter around when you have nothing but
the vacuum energy there's no right or
wrong way to slice it so you can't even
say whether it's expanding or not
anyway that was a slight digression to
get the subtleties of the sitter space
exactly right but if you say well okay
but in this case we're not exactly into
sitter space right we're in our current
Universe which will eventually empty out
more and more but there's always going
to be like one or two atoms floating
around so slice it in that frame that is
given to us by those that thin gruel of
remaining atoms okay so the universe
does not stop spanding expanding to
answer Paul's question but it does stop
Cooling and the reason why is because
the temperature is no longer a feature
of the physical matter and again this is
a subtlety sorry about this but you know
no one ever said general relativity and
Quantum field Theory would be easy in
the current Universe we have a cosmic
microwave background right we have uh
photons out there in space with an
average temperature of about 2.7 Kelvin
pretty darn cold okay but in the sitter
space it's not those photons that are
giving us the temperature sure it's the
temperature of the vacuum itself
it is a feature of decider space that
empty space the lowest energy State you
can possibly be in has a Quantum State
for the quantum fields that has a
non-zero temperature and the temperature
is very very low you know 10 to the
minus I don't know what it is 10 to the
minus
30 Kelvin something like that eventually
it will be but way way lower than the
current Cosmic microwave background is
see I've been doing Philosophy for too
long I've forgotten all the numbers that
I used to know for the Universe
um but this is a feature of the vacuum
state in a space time that has a horizon
it's exactly the same kind of phenomenon
that gives black holes their temperature
right a black hole has a temperature
even if there's no stuff around it it's
because the vacuum state of the quantum
fields in the presence of the black
holes Event Horizon is a thermal State
one with a non-zero temperature in the
case of decider space there's a horizon
not over there where the black hole is
because there's no black holes but
around you in every direction there is a
horizon surrounding every Observer and
that Horizon has the feature that it
gives the vacuum state of the quantum
field Theory a non-zero temperature I'm
not going to go into more details than
that but the point is roughly if I if I
wanted to cut this short to answer
Paul's question in decider space in the
way that you're thinking about it the
universe is still expanding but it is no
longer cooling it approaches the state
with a constant expansion rate rate and
a constant non-zero temperature and if
you're worried where the energy comes
from it's from space time itself that's
the best we can do
all right Tom Hawkins says I better
hurry up I'm getting this is giving too
much time to each question here Tom
Hawkins says black holes have been
proposed to be the source of some if not
all the Dark Matter do you have any
comments on this uh you know look it's
possible so the reason why I wanted to
answer this question remember for those
of you who don't already know I choose
questions on the basis of not if the
questions are good or bad but on do I
have anything interesting to say about
them that might not have already been
said
um in this case the thing to emphasize
is black holes are perfectly good
candidates for dark matter what do you
want for dark matter you want to be dark
so no electrically charged particles
that's a good idea uh and you want to be
matter in other words not radiation so
you want them to be slowly moving
particles generally that means massive
but at least a little bit of mass they
can't be moving at the speed of light
and you want them to be distributed in
more or less the right way and that's a
that's a sort of more more technical
requirement but there you go other than
that anything that fits those categories
those um characteristics could be dark
matter so the most popular particle
candidates are weekly interacting
massive particles wimps and axions which
were proposed in the 70s to solve a
problem in the strong interactions of of
the standard model
black holes are another perfectly good
possibility they could be small but they
can't be too small the black holes are
small they evaporate away and they're no
longer dark matter but if they're big
enough to have not yet evaporated then
they could be massive particle-like
things that uh are cold right cold Dark
Matter the problem is the reason why
they're not nearly as popular as these
particles well let me say the good thing
about black holes is they're known to
exist okay so unlike the wimps or the
axions we know that there are black
holes we've seen them by oligo and the
Nobel Prize was just given to people who
study the black hole the center of our
galaxy and Sagittarius a
um the bad news is we don't know the a
way of making them in the right
abundance to be dark matter and that's
the crucial thing which I think that
people don't always appreciate that for
the wimps and for the axions it's not
just that they're particles that are
dark and matter-like that's not why they
are the popular dark American as part of
it but the real reason is that the
evolution of those particles in the
early Universe can very naturally give
rise to exactly the right amount of
particles to be the observed amount of
dark matter you don't have to work very
hard in the case of the wimps it happens
almost automatically this is what we
call the wimp miracle if you have weekly
interacting massive particles you don't
have to try very hard to get exactly The
observed density of matter in the case
of axions it's not as clear you know you
can uh you can get the right abundance
but you have to like tune a parameter
it's not like tuned to be some special
value but you have to fix an arbitrary
free parameter to get the right
abundance of particles and you can do
that and it's not that hard to do it
there's no reason not to do it so you
can think of it as there was a parameter
we didn't know and we've observed it by
measuring the abundance of dark matter
but um in either case it's not that hard
to get the abundance in the case of
black holes you know where do these
black holes come from well who made them
you have to work pretty hard to invent a
mechanism in the early universe that
makes that many black holes because
remember the amount of Dark Matter
something like five times as much as the
amount of ordinary matter in the
universe
so where did all that density of black
holes come from then you can do it you
can sort of play games with very very
large density fluctuations at very very
small scales in the early universe that
are so small you don't see them directly
in the microwave background or whatever
but big enough that they sort of
collapse into black holes but it's hard
it's not natural it's very Baroque very
awkward looking and so black holes are
absolutely a candidate but they're not a
very popular candidate in the list of
most uh working physicists
Andrew Goldstein says respect for data
generated by and conclusions drawn from
scientifically sound research appears to
be in Decline especially when it
contradicts held beliefs how do you
think the rest of us science Believers
can help facilitate more people to
listen to what scientist science has to
say about everything from vaccines to
climate change to emergence
emergence is a bit of a surprise there I
didn't know emergence was like a Hot
Topic in science denialist story circles
but you know maybe it is maybe I've not
been reading the right Twitter feeds
um yeah and this is going to be a
similar you know I wanted to answer the
question because I think it's an
important question to ask but I don't
think that my answer is going to be
especially enlightening
similarly to the question about how we
support democracy the short answer is I
have no great ideas here again there are
people who have studied this and I've
read a little bit of what they've
written you know there's little tricks
like you know if you want to dissuade
people from believing some myth okay so
like let's think the Earth is flat this
is a special case so it's not a great
example but at least you know most
people listening to this podcast are not
going to believe the Earth is flat so
I'm not insulting anybody
um it turns out the Studies have shown
and these are difficult psychology
studies so you have to worry if they're
replicable and so forth but people try
if you want to persuade people the Earth
is not flat
you do not do things like say some
people say the Earth is flat here's why
they're wrong okay and that's a bad
strategy for two reasons number one is
you're leading with the myth with the
mistake and very often apparently this
is what the studies seem to say when you
do that the thing that people remember
is the myth not the refutation of the
myth so you have to lead with the true
thing first and then you can say as
opposed to the myth which says this so
you can you should say you know the
Earth is round despite some people
thinking that it's flat
Etc the other thing wrong with it is
this just argumentative rather than
persuasive as I mentioned in the
Democracy discussion you know you have
to treat the people you're talking to
like people like people who like you are
trying their best to understand things
and get the right answer and making
mistakes sometimes we all make mistakes
sometimes now of course again there are
extremists there are people who are not
trying to get get the right answer there
are people who are just lying for
whatever reasons forget about those
people okay that's a different problem
I'm thinking about the vast number of
people who are kind of trying their best
you know but maybe they're listening to
bad resources or uh just have a reason
that a certain problem is difficult for
them or they have some prejudices of
their own Etc
which basically means all of us okay we
all have biases we all are making
mistakes somehow and it's very very hard
to realize that we've been wrong so
rather than just arguing with people who
don't want to be argued with you know
try to see things their way you know try
to legitimately ask yourself
why would they think that if someone
believes that vaccines cause autism or
cancer or whatever where someone
believes the Earth is flat or climate
change is just a hoax hooked up by the
federal government and research
scientists to get more grant money
try to in good faith yourself figure out
why they would believe that if you're
talking to someone one-on-one or in a
small group you know like be and and
don't fake it you know really try to
understand why they would think that and
and that means both listening to the
reasons they would give for thinking
that but also maybe digging a little bit
more deeply and and wondering why they
might be so distrustful of authority
maybe they have some very good reasons
to be distrustful of authority uh and
that leads over into their beliefs about
other things you know and then work
within their existing belief system say
like well if you think this then maybe
you should think that okay like try to
discuss try to have a legitimate
conversation rather than just lecturing
and hectoring people now out in the
broader picture when you don't have a
one-on-one discussion but you're
broadcasting out there into the world
you know
Again part of it is just saying true
things and letting those true things
propagate another is to say true things
in a way that seems friendly and
approachable and reasonable and
admirable right be the role model be the
good guys be the people that other
people will look up to and want to be
rather than being an annoying scold
um and you know I try to do this myself
sometimes the temptation of being
annoying is cold is just overwhelming
and I give in we all do okay uh but this
is how we can try and none of this is
guaranteed to work I guess you know
um uh so I don't know so that's why I'm
saying like I don't have great
suggestions here but I do think the
problem is important so I want to let
people think about it themselves maybe
the people listening will have some
better ideas than I do but again if you
think you have better ideas that's great
I'm happy to hear them myself and you
know leave them in the comments section
Etc but what I would ask is have
evidence be based ideas don't just say
well I think this is how you do it okay
look for evidence that this particular
strategy that you're suggesting actually
works those are the suggestions that are
really interesting we all have
Impressions but these are difficult
questions how to talk to other people
and how to change their minds and so
ways that are backed up by science are
the best ways to think about
okay Anonymous says I saw a PBS
space-time video where Matt O'Dowd
explores whether it's possible that the
Big Bang is a Time reversed black hole
AKA a white hole my question is
supposing that it's possible for a white
hole to have black holes inside of its
Event Horizon would it also be possible
for a black hole to have white holes
inside of its Event Horizon
hmm so I think uh there's some things
that I can say with confidence about
this and other things that are a little
bit trickier
um I mean the short answer is yes it
absolutely would be possible because the
fundamental thing to keep in mind is
what is a white hole a white hole is
exactly a black hole played backward in
time
this is why we don't see white holes
around us all the time a white hole
would be something out of which things
could come but you couldn't get into
it's everything about a white hole is
just come up with the analogous thing
for a black hole and say it backwards in
time so in a black hole there's a region
of space-time you can enter but never
leave a white hole is a region of
space-time things can come out of but
not go into okay that's what it is so a
black hole has a singularity in the
future if you enter a black hole you
will hit the singularity inevitably a
white hole has a singularity in the past
there's a singularity out of which
things come you can't get there as you
are traveling into the future so the
reason why there's no white holes lying
around is that they're thermodynamically
crazy it's exactly like having you know
uh scrambled eggs turning into eggs or
glasses of water spontaneously forming
ice cubes Etc all of these reversing
entropy things are analogous to white
holes white holes decrease the entropy
of the universe just by existing okay
um
now the one big exception to that is the
Big Bang itself because we have this
rule the second law of Thermodynamics
entropy increases with time
um why does that happen well a big part
of the explanation is we started out at
Early times with very low entropy and
that's the part we don't know why that
happens some of us have ideas but we're
not sure why so the Big Bang cosmology
is highly analogous to a white hole it
really is very very similar it's not
exactly but it only depends on exactly
how you're defining white hole because
sometimes you know for a black hole we
Define it as a region of space time that
is finite
that is somehow bounded in size right I
mean the black hole is not the whole
universe it's just part of the universe
and you can enter it the the very idea
that you can enter the Horizon but not
Escape implies The Horizon has a finite
domain there right
that's the real only difference between
the Big Bang cosmology and a white hole
because a white hole has a singularity
in the past the Big Bang has a
singularity in the past the white hole
starts with uh low entropy and well the
white hole would do that I'm not even
sure I guess you could do it either way
but traditionally it you could do it if
you were
yeah I don't know what to say about that
um I think a white hole could either
have low entropy or high entry but the
actual Big Bang starts with low entropy
and entropy increases from there but
there's a thermodynamic miracle that is
involved namely why the original Big
Bang had such low entropy at those Early
Times
um but again of course inside our
white hole-like cosmology there are
black holes formed so for the question
could you have black holes inside white
holes
um just time reverse everything and you
can get everything you want that doesn't
mean it's thermodynamically sensible but
there will always be some solution to
the microscopic equations in which that
happens
I guess this is relatedly so Lewis B
says I'm curious about the past
hypothesis is implications on our
ability to rigorously study the past
hypothesis you seem to indicate at times
that even when trying to scientifically
study the entropy of the early Universe
the mere process of making observations
and drawing inferences itself must
already presume the past hypothesis it
would seem that we are forced into at
least some form of circular reasoning
while trying to conduct science on the
question of the entropy of the early
universe so I know what you mean Lewis
but I don't think it's circular
reasoning really I would say it's a
matter of being self-consistent okay so
what is being referred to here is that
we observe things like the distribution
of galaxies at Early times or the cosmic
microwave background radiation and we
say oh look it's in a configuration
which has lower entropy than the
universe today and that's not very hard
most of the entropy in the universe
today is in the form of black holes and
we don't see any black holes in the past
so it's the the
um
conclusion that the entropy of the early
Universe was lower at Early times does
not rely on any fancy observations we
have to do just that there are a lot of
black holes now and there weren't that
many then big supermassive kinds of
black holes uh the entropy of the single
black hole the center of our galaxy is
the is larger than the entropy that the
whole universe used to have Near The
Cosmic microwave background era
okay but how do we get to that
conclusion because after all as I've
said in other contexts when we observe
the microwave background or distant
galaxies or whatever we're not observing
them
from the point of view of when that
light got emitted from those phenomena
you know in the story that we tell the
cosmic microwave background is light
that lasts scattered about 380
000 years after the big bang okay and
now the universe is like 14 billion
years old
so we're inferring what things were like
on the basis of the light that we're
observing today
what we're actually observing is not
conditions 380 000 years after the big
bang what we're observing is the
radiation coming into our telescopes
today and we use our theoretical
framework to work backwards to see what
that implies about the early Universe at
very time ever the about the universe at
Early Times
um and we say it implies it had a low
entropy but that does imply that does
assume that entropy has been increasing
all along so you assume that entropy has
been increasing and then you infer from
your observations that the specific kind
of low entropy state looks like the
following thing so we're not assuming
the specific low entropy or release date
we're assuming the basic rough idea that
entropy is increasing then taking the
observations that we see and inferring a
specific kind of low entropy state so
it's it's not a completely circular
argument but it is a self-consistent
argument and you know it could be wrong
that's the important thing
we cannot guarantee with any
metaphysical certainty that the early
Universe did have a low entropy because
we can't even guarantee there was an
early Universe God could have created
the whole universe last Thursday we
could be brains in a vat being taunted
by an evil demon we could be
fluctuations from a high entropy State
at Early Times none of those ideas
are things you can rule out on the basis
of data once and for all you can assign
them low Credence you can do that and
then you can see is that a fruitful
thing to do can I make progress on the
basis of doing that and that's what we
do with the low entropy Big Bang we say
well if it was high entropy then our
existence is just a crazy accident and
we know nothing reliable about the
universe and that's fine but it's no way
to go through life you could say or
hypothetically maybe the early Universe
had a low entropy then what follows from
that and what follows from that is a
sensible picture of how the universe
evolved and confidence that other
implications that we draw about the
universe are reliable so the past
hypothesis is called a hypothesis
because you can't prove it
but making it makes everything fit
together in a nice way
and it didn't have to I mean you could
assume the past hypothesis and then go
out and make an observation and see the
universe looks like it was high entropy
in the past right and that would be a
refutation but you can't prove it but
you haven't disproven it either and it
works in a self-consistent way that's
life that's life as a scientist you can
never know the evil demon is not
taunting you but it's no way to go
through the day
Sid Huff says in listening to your
mindscape interviews I've noticed that
many of your guests have recently
published a book furthermore it seems
clear from the interviews that you've
almost always read or absorbed their
book prior to the interview is reading
these books included in the one day per
week you've mentioned that you spend on
the podcast uh yes it is but of course
some
interviews require more reading than
others so it's not like it's lit when I
say it's one day per week that's an
expectation value that's an average some
require less some require more and
remember you know one of the big
motivations for me doing the podcast at
all is that I like reading these books I
mean these are things that I would like
to be learning about anyway you know
this is one of the reasons why I think
um they're fun conversations that we
have because it's not like I am a
professional interviewer who's been told
by some producer that this person would
be interesting to talk to the people I'm
talking to are people who I want to be
talking to and they often have books
because it's easier to get people on the
podcast when they have a book to
publicize that's a very natural thing to
do and so it's a mutual back scratching
kind of arrangement and finally most
importantly it's possible that I have
not read every word of the book
I do try to get the point of the book
right like sometimes I will read every
word but other times the books are long
I'm in a hurry
um I'm trying to get enough of a point
that I can ask relevant questions so you
know the the line you want to
um walk on here is I don't want to sort
of tell the guest what to say right so
it's not like I want to go okay now we
have to talk about this and we're
talking about chapter three now and
there's a there's a whole outline before
we start but I also don't want to like
miss something really interesting so the
real reason for
reading the book is that there could be
really juicy stuff in there that I don't
want to neglect to ask about you know in
principle you don't need to read
anything because you're having the
person on you can just ask them the
questions right they're right there in
front of you you have Marshall mclu in
there you can ask him questions uh but
the real worry is that you're going to
miss something interesting that they
have to say so I always tell my guests
you know look you know more than I do
about this subject so feel free to talk
about the interesting stuff but then I
also try to give them the space to do
that by asking questions that are
inspired by the stuff that is in their
books
F sub H is the name given to this person
who says just to make things clear in my
head when you say the universe can
fluctuate into existence I think you
said that does this really mean that
fluctuations in the sitter space can
cause Elementary particles to randomly
come together in a configuration that
creates an entire universe just like
ours if so isn't this then the answer to
the question about the origin of our
universe how can we disprove that it
wasn't created in this way also there's
a bunch of ideas in there just to clear
things up so the first thing to say is
yes it is possible
that fluctuations in the sitter sprays
can cause Elementary particles to
randomly come together in a
configuration that creates an entire
universe just like ours this was uh
something people have talked about I
think you know uh Dyson kleben and
suskind Lenny suskin former mindscape
guest was one of the first papers to
write about this
um and then I wrote a paper with Anthony
Aguirre another mindscape guests and
Matt Johnson that went into more details
about what that would actually look like
okay this process of fluctuating in a
whole new universe into existence it's
also possible it doesn't happen okay
even in the sitter space the nature of
the fluctuations is uh not completely
clear thing so do you get into sitter
space the kind of fluctuations that give
rise to a universe or do brains or do
people or whatever unclear or what I
should say is it depends on other
details you can't just say the sitter
space therefore fluctuations you have to
say deciders space plus these extra
hypotheses and then you'll know whether
or not there are those kinds of
fluctuations or not it's a model
dependent kind of question
final thing to say is
no this is not the explanation for how
our universe came to be that's exactly
the boltzmann brain problem if you're in
a situation where you do have decider
space the center space lasts forever
okay it's Eternal to the past and future
and if you have fluctuations that
randomly create universes you will also
always have fluctuations that randomly
create smaller parts of organized
subsystems people planets galaxies
whatever and you're going to make
individual people or planets way more
often than you're going to make entire
universes so that's a theory that could
explain the origin of our universe but
that theory makes predictions and the
prediction is we don't live in a whole
universe like that we live in a much
much smaller Universe than you would
have gotten that way so the theory is
not compatible with how we think the
universe actually works I don't want to
say it's ruled out by the data for
complicated reasons dealing with
cognitive uncertainty that I talk about
in my paper why both men brains are bad
but the short answer is we do not think
this is a plausible explanation for
where our universe came from it doesn't
fit other things we know about the
universe
Trevor vilwalk says priority question
remember that every uh patreon gets once
in their life the ability to ask a
priority question that I will promise to
try very hard to answer I don't
necessarily promise that the answer will
be satisfying but at least I'll give it
a shot
um so the priority question is shouldn't
we consider the default rational view of
an afterlife to be that life repeats
eternally rather than simply ending at
your death and then Trevor gives a lot
more explanation what he means by that
patreons you can read that in the uh in
the comments where the questions are
left
um so no I don't think that is is true
at all so let me just I I'm not sure
that I got the scenario that Trevor was
outlining in his question so let me at
least try to say something useful by
saying what I think my view is
um
I think that life is a process I don't
think it is in essence okay so the
distinction being drawn is between a
literal substance versus a way of
describing the Dynamics of some kind of
other substance right so like this is
not a very spooky kind of Distinction
when you think about energy
is not a substance either energy is a
property that substances have you know
substances can have kinetic energy or
potential energy or whatever but it's a
thing that has that energy an atom or a
rock or planet or what have you and the
energy is the way we talk about it the
way we characterize that physical thing
I think that life is like that although
unlike energy life is not conserved okay
life is a temporary process it begins at
the beginning of Life it ends at the end
the boundaries and actually this is
going to be a theme it's going to re
recur later on in um the AMA the
boundaries of when life begins and when
life ends are not necessarily cut and
dried okay
um when you we're thinking about this of
course because the question of abortion
and Roe versus Wade is on the docket
right now in contemporary politics so
that's not what this particular question
is about so let's think about the other
end let's think about death death is not
cut and dried either you can have
different parts of your body shutting
down at different moments in time we you
can have you can be dead by all
um scientific criteria but if you've
recently died maybe you can be revived
right because life is not a substance
that left the body some sort of ilon
vital that was located in your body and
went somewhere else it's a process and
you die because the process stops and if
your body has not broken down too much
doctors can come in there and quickly
restart the process and it keeps going
and you can keep your memories in the
whole bit okay but eventually it will
stop and the fact that the boundary the
moment when you actually die is not cut
and dried is completely compatible with
the fact that it does stop so I started
saying this is going to be the theme of
the AMA
just because a certain category or idea
is not precisely exactly rigorously
defined does not mean it's not super
duper useful
so whether or not a thing is alive or
dead might not be super duper rigorously
well defined but it is still pretty
clear in some circumstances and
therefore it is a very useful concept to
have so if you know a person dies and
then they're cremated and their ashes
are spread around
they're dead they're never going to come
back there's no uh necessary sense in
which they repeat eternally the other
that's the sort of physical biological
aspect the cosmological aspect here is
does anything repeat eternally and you
know the answer there is maybe maybe not
there's certainly no reason to think
that anything in the universe repeats
eternally we don't know the universe had
a beginning whether or not it will have
an end and if it does last forever if
the universe is eternal it's again
possible that it's a Eternal and a
repetitive sense but it's also possible
it's Eternal in a non-repetitive sense
so my favorite sorry to those who've
heard this before my favorite example is
the integers the numbers right zero one
two three four also minus one minus two
minus three minus four
an infinite number of integers and they
never repeat
even though there's an infinite number
of them there's only one of them that is
the number five okay and the universe
could be like that it could be Eternal
but no one moment ever repeats and in
fact I think there's very good reasons
to think that if the universe is eternal
it would be like that and again it's a
complicated story but it goes back to
similar boltzmann brain kind of
considerations if the universe recurred
if there was a finite number of things
that could happen and they happen in
infinitely many times probably again not
certainly but probably they would happen
more often than not in low entropy
fluctuations in in small fluctuations
away from thermal equilibrium I should
say our universe is a huge
distinction distinction Divergence from
thermal equilibrium so it's not the kind
of universe you would expect to live in
if we lived in a in a recurring Universe
I talk about this a lot more in the book
from eternity to here if you want to
know more about that
Carlos Nunes says between the view of
Francis fukiyama that all the world will
progress toward a global capitalist
Democratic order and Samuel Huntington's
view of Warring civilizations and
Perpetual conflict due to profound
cultural differences which position
seems more reasonable to you can
non-western civilizations such as China
ever Embrace Western democratic values
so the answer is I don't really buy into
either one of those parts of the
dichotomy so certainly not the idea of
fukiyama that uh the universe is
progress the universe the world here on
Earth is progressing toward a global
capitalist Democratic order and I don't
want to completely pooh-pooh the idea I
mean I get it there is there are there
is not uh you know a teleology in the
progress of history but there are trends
that go on for a long time and I think
it's okay to imagine that the universe
is becoming more uh globalist capitalist
Democratic than it was before
um but I also think that there is some
inherent instability and some churn you
know I think that it is probably a
mistake to think that there is in human
culture ever going to be a permanent or
quasi-permanent equilibrium
you know especially and but this is hard
to say like maybe there will be
but when you're in you know human beings
are coupled to technology in the
environment and things like that what I
should say is human social and political
systems are coupled to the environment
here on Earth and also to technology all
the ways in which we can change our
environment through science and
engineering and so forth and both the
environment and Technology are in states
of Rapid change right now right they are
nowhere near equilibrium we're dumping
greenhouse gases and we're killing off
species and things like that and we're
developing new technologies uh new ways
of uh changing our everyday lives and so
it would be very very very very
surprising to me if human culture and
politics somehow stayed constant in a
world where the surrounding boundary
conditions were changing rapidly okay
we're changing dramatically and even if
the surrounding boundary conditions were
more or less constant it's still very
plausible to me that human societies
would be changing you know I think that
a characteristic of Life at the very
basic level of what it means to be a
living being is that it is an out of
equilibrium process right we take in low
and low entropy energy from the Sun we
give it back to the universe and we sort
of survive on that dynamical process and
that's not directly related to politics
or culture but it's an analogy
um human culture is also an out of
equilibrium process it is not something
you should expect to settle into an
equilibrium it's not that it can't there
are
quasi-equilibrium processes that are uh
in some sense dynamical right you know a
hurricane can last for a while the Great
Red Spot on Jupiter is a better example
because
hurricanes don't last for very long but
the Great Red Spot is not you know some
big rock that is red it's a storm it's a
dynamical thing the individual molecules
move in and out of the great red spot
but the pattern lasts for a long time
even though the thing as a whole is out
of equilibrium so you could imagine
human culture being like that taking in
information and energy giving it back
out and yet maintaining some kind of
overall homeostatic configuration
but I don't see it I don't see that
happening right now so certainly I think
that it is a very very short-term
blinkered perspective to think that the
very very recent changes in human
culture are going to last forever or
even for centuries you know I I think
that that's unlikely on the other hand
Huntington's view of Warring
civilizations seems to me to be
in some sense a Flip Flip Side of the
same short-sighted coin right to take
current conditions and extrapolate them
to Forever
um even if there's churn and change and
dynamism in human society the idea that
it will just take the form of the kinds
of conflict between cultures that we
have right now just seems wrong to me
cultures change they intermix and we're
clearly in a stage of human development
right now where those changing and
mixing are rapid and important so to
somehow take some aspects of that and
imagine that they're frozen in and will
last forever seems you know even if I
don't know what the actual future is
going to be like I'm gonna bet that it's
not going to be that and that seems very
improbable to probable to me now you
tacked on an extra question the rules
are only one question but again you know
I always bend the rules it's it's my
podcast what what can you do you can't
stop me
um Can non-western civilizations such as
China ever Embrace Western democratic
values and I just can't let that one go
because I think that the there's a many
assumptions being smuggled in here that
I don't want to Grant
um I think it's just completely bogus to
think of democratic values as Western
and to contrast them with Eastern or
Chinese or Asian values any sense in
both senses in both the sense that
democracy is Western or that Western is
democracy okay anyone who knows the
history of Western Civilization if you
want to call it that mostly
non-democratic over the course of
history right some including very
recently including right now some very
brutal autocratic
cultures societies governments there's
there's democracies there but that has
not been the consistent story for the
last three thousand years in the Western
World by any means it's been mostly
dictatorships and autocracies in the
western world and
if you have not uh heard it or if you
don't remember I encourage everyone to
go back and listen to the podcast I did
with David to Savage about the origin of
democracy it is not an exclusively
Western idea okay there have been
democracies all over the place now
what's going on of course is that the
Western World the European world and its
sort of cultural descendants did catch
on to the Industrial Revolution the
Scientific Revolution and the
enlightenment first and that that
managed to let them you know colonize
the world and there's a very fascinating
interrelationship between those changes
and the changes of um democracy and uh I
don't even know what to call it the you
know the Age of Reason uh and
Enlightenment on the political side of
things I'm sure that there's a
well-known phrase that I'm just
forgetting right now uh I've not gotten
a lot of sleep because moving across the
country is is tiresome but the point is
um there's been in the last couple of
centuries a Resurgence of democratic
governance in the Western World yes to
think of this as somehow culturally
alien to uh Asia or something like that
is just entirely wrong in my view and I
think that it's that it's clear why
people try to do it the people who try
to do it are the autocratic dictators
that are ruling countries in China and
elsewhere right they want to provide an
excuse for not being Democratic because
they like the power that they have and
there are certain apologists that they
have who are not them themselves but I
think it's entirely bogus you know maybe
I'm certainly willing to imagine there
is a relationship between culture and
governance I'm certainly willing to
imagine that different cultures will
settle on different kinds of Ideal forms
of government but you know Japan seems
to be doing pretty well with Democratic
governance even though it's not a
Western Country I think that
the idea of democracy can be implemented
in many different ways but its
fundamental Foundation is the idea that
the authority comes from the will of the
people
not from some special Elite that gets
the right to govern and I think that
that is a universal thing I think that's
a human thing I don't think that's a
western thing at all so I have no
trouble whatsoever in thinking that
countries elsewhere in the world can
Embrace Democratic Values even if not
Western values
okay I'm going to group two questions
together I really you know by the way
anyone listening I love doing these amas
um there there's something to do
um it takes time but it's well worth it
and part of the Delight for me is just
randomly popping from topic to topic and
talking about it might not always make
for the most coherent listening
experience but it's fun for me so thank
you for indulging me in this
so here are two questions scooping
together one from Justin Wolcott that
says the fine-tuning argument says that
the odds that the conditions of the
universe it supports life randomly
occurring is 10 to the minus 223.
but the odds that God would create a
universe that supports life is a hundred
percent therefore God is exponentially
more probable than no God the
fine-tuning problem argument itself
feels flawed by picking an arbitrary
phenomenon of life and applying a
success Criterion for a pet Theory after
the fact I can't put my finger on it but
this feels like a dishonest research
technique much like P hacking is it
and then Mark schwern says I'm currently
reading David chalmer's reality plus and
enjoying it I came across a statement
though that strikes me as Incorrect and
I'm curious about your thoughts on it he
says that a weakness to the Multiverse
as a solution to the fine-tuning problem
is that it only bumps the problem up a
level because the Multiverse would have
to be fine-tuned to allow for universes
suitable for life to come into being I
am under the impression that all we need
are string theory and inflation and we
end up with universes with a variety of
physical laws and we don't need some set
of laws for the Multiverse that
determine how many and what sort of
universes we get am I thinking about
this incorrectly so I'm grouping these
two questions together because they're
both about you know fine-tuning and the
Multiverse and things like that but
they're you know these are good these
are better than average questions about
fine-tuning in the Multiverse so I'd
like them
um Justin brings up this idea that the
probability of getting a universe that
can that supports life is 10 to the
minus 223 and I've seen numbers like
this bandied about before and they are
completely entirely bogus sorry about
that people who like these numbers uh
the way they get them is they take some
parameter in the universe like you know
the fine structure constant or whatever
the ratio of the neutron Mass to the
proton Mass a million different numbers
the cosmological constant not a million
but a lot large number of numbers and
then they completely pull out of their
butts some probability distribution for
these numbers and you know by the way
bless them for doing that because
particle physicists do it all the time
too particle physicists who have no
interest in fine-tuning in the sense of
design or God or whatever they make up
probability distributions for no good
reason and I think that this is a
disastrous flaw in the entire discussion
of these issues and this is one of the
reasons why we need better philosophy
here because these physicists and these
theologians are just making [ __ ] up and
we should be better than that so anyway
they uh invent a bunch of probability
distributions for numbers to have and
then they guess or kind of try to
estimate
um the range that those numbers need to
have in order for life to exist and the
ranges are small and they multiply
together a whole bunch of small numbers
and they get this ridiculously tiny
number 10 to the minus 223. so there's a
lot of Elementary mathematical mistakes
that they make uh in doing that even
besides inventing these probabilities
fusions they often then treat these
probability distributions as independent
of each other you know the probability
distribution for the fine structure
constant and then the probability
distribution that you know the
temperature of the air on the earth will
have a certain value or whatever but
these are not independent of each other
so you just can't do that so this is
sort of a very simple mistake that is
being made
but the bigger mistake is just this idea
that we know the probability of a
universe like ours there's two big
mistakes one is that we know the
probability of the universe like ours
um that number one sorry there's sort of
sub mistakes the one big mistake is we
know we can calculate the probability of
universe like ours okay the sub mistakes
are number one we can calculate the
probability distribution for individual
constants okay but number two that
somehow a universe that is more or less
like ours but with these constants is
the only kind of universe that we could
have right
um a universe that is a Multiverse kind
of universe is completely compatible
with all the um observations we have
maybe a Multiverse is a 50 chance and if
that's true or maybe it's a one percent
chance whatever but anyway there's zero
reason to thank the Multiverse has a
chance of 10 to the minus 223 so it's
just an entirely bogus kind of uh
calculation done by people who already
think that they know what the right
answer is supposed to be
um
and then the other thing that they're
assuming is that we know the probability
that life can exist right and here I do
think that there are some conditions
that you could imagine a universe having
that would be so incredibly hostile to
complex structures existing at all that
all of us will be willing to grant that
yeah life could not exist there but
I don't I have any confidence at all
that in a somewhat complicated Universe
you can pinpoint whether or not
different kinds of Life Could exist
these calculations generally want to
make life really really really
human-like and leave no room for other
very very different kinds of life like
complex structures okay
um so I think that these calculations
are completely entirely wrong-headed now
I also think of the fine-tuning argument
is uh wrong for other reasons for better
reasons this is not the real reason why
the fine-tuning argument is wrong the
the real reasons why it's wrong are
number one
um God wouldn't need to fine-tune the
universe for life to exist life the the
fine-tuning argument only works if
you're already a naturalist or a
physicalist about life because if God
existed then the physical Universe could
do anything at all and life would not be
purely physical right if life is just an
emerging phenomenon from complex
structures in the universe that sounds
like you're already a naturalist there
and so what you're calculating is the
probability that a naturalist Universe
would exist that allows for the
existence of life but God can create
life in any Universe at all so that's a
really Dopey argument for the existence
of God
um and the second huge problem with it
is that as a good Bayesian you you
should you're not allowed to just say oh
I have one piece of data life exists and
I'm going to calculate the relative
probability that this happens with God
or without God if that were the only
thing you cared about the only data you
had then I would actually be willing to
buy that the preponderance of that data
is more favorable towards theism than
naturalism because if that's I get that
you could invent a version of theism
where God would definitely want life to
exist but then you gotta be consistent
then you got to be able to say okay what
other predictions should you make for
what the universe should be like under
this theistic Theory and there you start
making predictions and you find a
universe very very different than what
we live in so that idea is more or less
ruled out by the data if you're a
consistent good Bayesian so anyway
fine-tuning argument entirely bogus I
have said and I will stand by the idea
that it is the best argument for the
Existence for God because it plays by
the rules it's an argument that tries to
be Bay Bayesian right tries to say well
we have some priors we update them
uh and and we draw conclusions on the
basis of that unlike these ideas that
just let us sit in our armchairs and
just reason into the existence of uh
transcendental being like a you know a
necessary being or something like that
which those are even more bogus
um so it does it tries to play by the
rules in that sense but I think that you
know it's still not very good at it and
then to Mark's question you know
um about David chalmers's objection to
the Multiverse yeah I also disagree with
that completely and I agree with David
about a lot of things but I disagree
with them about a lot of things also I
think that he is
um
I I don't remember reading that section
of the book to be perfectly honest
reality plus which is a very a great
book by the way you should definitely
check it out if you haven't it's
extremely readable even though it's
discussing a high level of philosophical
things
um it's a fun read to be honest he
really did a good job at writing a a
very accessible book but this argument
that the Multiverse has to be fine-tuned
as I just don't think is is right
um the whole idea of a Multiverse is
there's some simple generating principle
that creates all sorts of different
universes I mean maybe that generating
principles the combination of string
theory and inflation that's the popular
one that we're thinking of now but uh
you know it's it's again it's like the
integers you know I don't need to invent
an infinite number of numbers I need to
invent a single number zero and a single
operation that adds one okay and then
boom I haven't even number of numbers
and the Multiverse is like that it's a
very simple process that gives rise to
all these universes and so no necessary
fine-tuning is involved
Bruno Tashara says there have been some
news about a new particle discovered the
axial Higgs boson or the magnetic Higgs
I read the abstract of the article but
it was out of my league can we get your
take on it well yeah I'll give you a
mini take here uh because I think there
is some clarification even though I'm
not a super expert on what is actually
done I am an expert on what was not done
which was discovering a new particle
there the old Higgs boson that we
discovered before is still the old Higgs
boson that's the only particle that we
have that fits that description within
the standard model
but here's the thing the Higgs is part
of a mechanism right the Higgs mechanism
and the mechanism is you could have a
symmetry in some kind of theory like uh
gauge symmetry that is to say a way of
transforming Fields where everything
remains unchanged when you do the
transformation and the Higgs mechanism
is some other field that transforms
under that symmetry gets a non-zero
value in empty space a so-called vacuum
expectation value and when that happens
the Symmetry looks like it's been broken
so we call that spontaneous symmetry
breaking or
um non-linearly realized symmetry or
something like that but anyway you
wouldn't notice the Symmetry if all you
knew was life inside that vacuum State
and that was the case for particle
physics you required some imagination
some IQ points to realize that there was
a symmetry there even though it was
apparently broken
but this idea of a Higgs mechanism is a
pretty general idea you know there's the
actual implementation of that idea in
the weak interactions of particle
physics in the so-called electroweak
theory that breaks down the su2 cross U1
symmetry of the standard model down to
just U1 which we see as electromagnetism
but then you can have similar mechanisms
in all sorts of other systems and this
so-called new particle that was
discovered it got a little bit of press
and coverage recently was of that form
it was a completely different system it
was a condensed matter system nothing
like the fundamental particle physics of
the electric weak model or anything like
that and they saw a different kind of
Higgs mechanism that they call the axial
Higgs boson or the magnetic eggs
whatever it's not a new particle in the
standard model and honestly uh the set
of people who are responsible for this
news story are you know they were bad
they misbehaved I don't know whether the
blame goes with a press office at a
universe diversity or the scientists
themselves or whoever but you can say
things that are technically true in a
press release but you know if you're
honest with yourself are going to be
misinterpreted by everybody and this is
exactly in that League when you say I've
discovered a new Higgs boson they people
are going to naturally think that you
discovered something extra beyond the
standard model of particle physics or a
new part of the standard model and
that's certainly not what happened here
so that's a little bit of bad PR
mongering I would say
Nicholas Chapman says Boltzmann's
formula for entropy gives entropy is
proportional to the log of the number of
microstates for a given macrostate use
using this definition the second law of
Thermodynamics then just becomes almost
a tautology that more likely states are
overwhelmingly more likely to occur in
the future how then is the second level
useful in any way when defined like this
well remember so you've already cheated
Nicholas by saying second that states
with higher entropy are more likely to
occur in the future who said anything
about the future Boltzmann's formula
doesn't say anything about the future it
just says that the entropy is
proportional to the log of number of
microstates okay anything you say about
the future if that's the only thing you
know Boltzmann's formula you should also
say about the past but in that case you
don't in the real world think that
entropy was overwhelmingly likely to be
larger in the past so you have to
augment Boltzmann's formula by the past
hypothesis as well as
some more specific kind of technical
requirement that you are not in the
highly Tiny But nevertheless accessible
kinds of states where entropy would
decrease even though it is not forced to
right you could sort of have a
conspiracy in all the molecules in your
gas or whatever to be pointed in an
entropy decreasing Direction so there is
content to the second law of
Thermodynamics it says not only is it
likely that entropy will increase from
today to tomorrow but that it was
smaller yesterday and that is not going
to pop out a Boltzmann's formula all by
itself
Richard Keenan asks a priority question
do you think it is acceptable to come to
conclusions about other political and
sociological situations like those in
China for example without conducting the
proper research and having evidence to
back up most people's claim that a
liberal democracy is the only civilized
way to govern a population it seems to
me that almost everyone gets their
information on places like China from
mainstream media who are known to lie
and to be biased in the extreme when it
comes to China in particular it is also
known that the U.S government has a
budget of millions to fund anti-chinese
propaganda when surely that money could
be better spent on U.S citizens welfare
so there's a lot going on in this
question
um I mean do you have a right to have an
opinion uh without conducting proper
research you know everyone has a right
to an opinion or to come to conclusions
what the better way of saying it is how
plausible or believable or credible are
the conclusions that you're reaching and
clearly the more evidence you have the
more proper research you've done the
more credible your conclusions are there
I could stop talking there that would be
an answer to the question but clearly
this this is one of those things that in
the lingo of the trade is more of a
comment than a question and trying to
make a point rather than ask a question
and the point being made I don't really
agree with at all so as soon as you know
just for future reference not anything
personal against you Richard but when
people start complaining about the
mainstream media I almost immediately
know to not take seriously what they're
saying because of course the mainstream
media is not always right of course the
mainstream media makes mistakes of
course it has its biases and it has
systematic biases where you can critique
it for very good reasons and I've done
that myself but guess what all the
non-stream mainstream media also has
biases and problems and typically more
biases and problems and prediledictions
for making mistakes than the mainstream
media does so the point is not
mainstream versus non-mainstream Media
the point is for any given information
Source how credible is it How likely is
its way of telling a story
um being to be influenced by its biases
and its prejudices and so forth and
I'm sure that the United States
government has propaganda I'm sure the
Chinese government has propaganda I'm
sure that Taiwan has propaganda and
Russia has propaganda all these things I
don't really think that's relevant to
this question
um and especially when surely that money
could be better spent on U.S citizens
welfare you know that's this is just not
a very you know rigorous comparison of
how we should allocate our budgetary
resources I think we can do a little bit
better than that
um finally the claim that a liberal
democracy is the only civilized way to
govern a population I very rarely if
ever hear people say that in those exact
words this seems like a little bit of a
twisting of what people say I do think
it's the best way to govern a population
I'd be happy to defend that
um certainly it's better than what China
does China is uh oppressive autocracy I
think that's just true I've been to
China there is never an election where
the Communist party wants to win and
doesn't that just doesn't happen okay
you can't get certain websites from the
outside world you cannot learn about
what happened at Tiananmen Square if
you're in China that is not the kind of
society that I want to live in for all
of the problems that we clearly have
here in the United States we have more
Freedom of Information more ability to
choose our leaders just because things
are not perfect here doesn't mean
they're not better than other places and
there are places that are worse than
China also so you have to actually take
some care to get things right on that I
completely agree
is it possible or reasonable to
formulate a version of many worlds
quantum mechanics without actually
believing in the many worlds in other
words using entanglement decoherence to
explain measurement collapse and the
associated probabilities as many worlds
does but being agnostic about whether
the other branches exist well I think
that you can't I don't think that being
agnostic is part of a scientific theory
that's just that's just not really a
thing right scientific theory is a set
of equations and a sort of
interpretation for what those equations
are telling you if you believe in the
Schrodinger equation unitary Evolution
as many worlds posits and you believe
that the wave function is realist that
it somehow represents aspects of reality
and you believe there's no violation of
the Schrodinger equation then the theory
predicts the existence of the Worlds so
either you believe that theory and you
believe in the worlds or you don't
believe in the theory so you have to
change the theory somehow you can't just
be agnostic about what the theory is
predicting you either think the theory
is right or you think it's wrong or of
course you have some Credence for
whichever thing but there's no stance
where you say I think the wave function
is realist and there are no hidden
variables and there's only Schrodinger
Evolution but I choose not to believe in
the other worlds that's just an
inconsistent attitude to have
Joy kolbeck says does the cosmic
microwave background have a spectral
signature uh yeah sure absolutely I mean
if you're my age there was a big deal
when I was in graduate school about the
spectrum of the cosmic microwave
background the Spectrum so just to go
way back uh to the basics here by
Spectrum we mean taking a set of
electromagnetic radiation or whatever
and decomposing it into the different
amounts that are coming to you from
different frequencies or wavelengths so
you can absolutely do that with the
cosmic microwave background and guess
what you get an almost perfect black
body spectrum that is to say you get the
same kind of spectrum from a system and
thermal equilibrium at a certain
temperature just giving off radiation
and that temperature is 2.7 Kelvin okay
so that is the Spectrum the sorry I
should back up again a little bit
because people use the word spectrum
with respect to the microwave background
in two very very different senses a
spectrum is just whenever you have a set
of waves
you talk about the different amount of
waves with different wavelengths okay so
in the actual microwaves in the cosmic
microwave background those are waves
they have wavelengths of order
centimeter and you can decompose them
into different wavelengths and that's
the spectrum of the cosmic microwave
background it's a black body okay but
then you also have density perturbations
in the early Universe right
those are the perturbations that give
rise to the anisotropies of temperature
in the cosmic microwave background and
eventually grow into galaxies and
structures and so as physicists tend to
do we instantly think of those
anisotropies and perturbations as a set
of waves okay as a set of modes in
Fourier space so you can talk about the
amount of perturbation at a certain
wavelength and another wavelength and
another wavelength and all together the
amounts of perturbations with different
wavelengths are the spectrum of
perturbations of the cosmic microwave
background so that's not a spectrum of
wavelengths of light it's a spectrum of
wavelengths of perturbations and rather
than centimeters we're talking about
millions of light years or whatever so
let's not talk about the perturbations
that's not what we're talking about the
spectral signature of the CMB itself is
almost a perfect black body
so to go back to where I started when I
was a graduate student there was a hint
from a telescope from a satellite
experiment actually that the microwave
background was actually not a perfect
black body there's a little deviation
from it
and on the one hand this is completely
expected you wouldn't expect any real
thing in nature to be an absolutely
perfect black body because there's
various ways to deviate something get in
the way something you know there could
be foregrounds that mess it up there can
be processes that push it out of
equilibrium you know exploding stars or
whatever energetic things happening in
the early universe and there was a claim
from uh was it even a satellite or was
it just a rocket I think it was a rocket
launched Observatory that didn't
actually orbit
um but anyway the claim was there was a
slight excess at long wavelengths in the
microwave background spectrum and an
enormous amount of effort went into
trying to explain the success and I even
have friends who did PhD Theses trying
to explain this excess and uh it went
away it was not there it was an artifact
of a bad experiment of a mistake they
were basically observing their own
rocket exhaust even though they tried
very hard not to do that and then when
the Kobe satellite went up the very
first thing it did was to observe the
spectrum of the CMB and it was the
perfect black body as far as it could be
observed so I think that even though it
needn't be an absolutely perfect black
body I believe it's still true that the
cosmic microwave background spectrum is
the best black body that we know of in
nature someday we'll find a deviation
from it but not yet
Dom says do you think physics can ever
be finished
um well it depends on what you mean by
finished I do think that we can find the
fundamental laws of nature there's a way
the universe works and we can find it I
don't see any obstacle to that I mean
maybe we won't I didn't say we will but
I think that they're there and I think
we have the intellectual ability to do
it in principle now there's more to
physics at the fundamental laws right
the fundamental laws might be a small
compact set of rules but the way that
those fundamental laws manifest in the
messy macroscopic world in the emergent
world if you like is of almost infinite
variety maybe not technically infinite
to a mathematician but really really
complex like in some sense
biology is a subset of physics right so
to understand all of physics means
understanding all biology and I don't
think that's going to happen uh at least
anytime soon so I don't think that
science will ever be finished although I
do think that it's possible that the
fundamental laws will be figured out and
then what physics will be doing is
mostly figuring out the implications of
those fundamental laws and that's what
most physics is even today so the
chances of finishing that uh in any
reasonable time frame are extremely tiny
indeed
Seamus McLennan or shelmas McLennan says
I would love to hear your thoughts on
Carl Popper's tolerance Paradox
personally I'm constantly frustrated by
friends who are on the liberal left who
constantly advocate for free speech
acknowledge that there is a line
somewhere but refuse to Define where
that line is so there's a couple things
going on here as usual
um the Paradox of Tolerance from Carl
popper we talked about in the mindscape
episode with Teresa Teresa Beijing I
encourage you to listen to that and
neither one of us are fans of poppers
tolerance Paradox the tolerance Paradox
is you try to be a tolerant Society but
that means you let anyone have speech
rights right Free Speech but then some
people who want to speak are not
themselves tolerant so by being tolerant
towards intolerant people you are
opening up the danger of them
overthrowing your society and making it
no more no longer tolerant and the
answer is you know yeah you are opening
up that danger but maybe me that's a
danger a risk that is worth taking
I believe that in most cases not not all
cases but in most cases when it comes to
the kind of discourse that is purely
about
political process or political Theory
even if it's intolerant even if it's
racist and sexist and tyrannical and
authoritarian even if it's like
pro-fascism I think that the way to deal
with that if you want to fight against
racism and sexism and fascism Etc is not
to prevent that kind of speech it is to
address the issues raised by that kind
of speech I think there is a more robust
way of being anti-racist that you get to
by knowing what it would mean to be
racist right by understanding why as I
said before with discussing with people
who you disagree with understanding why
they would ever think that is actually
important not because you're going to be
persuaded by it but because you want to
persuade them and you want to understand
your own point of view better and you do
that by listening I once wrote on
Twitter you know sometimes I write
things on Twitter that I think are
perfectly benign and why am I even
bothering and then I get a lot of abuse
for it and I said like did forget
exactly the phraseology but it was along
the lines of if you want to understand a
point of view listen to it from the
perspective of the people who believe
that point of view don't get all of your
information from the Skeptics of that
point of view because in that case
you're probably not getting the full
story and people really really objected
to that like what if the point of view
is bad
especially if the point of view is bad
that's when you should get it from the
horse's mouth because that's because
then it's a puzzle why do people have
these bad points of view well I mean you
could try to just think of them as
terrible evil people or you could listen
to what they're saying and so I think
that popper was wrong in that
um way of of framing the issue of what
to do with intolerant points of view now
having said that I'm not an absolutist
about free speech I think I'm probably I
have a wider scope for it than a lot of
people do but I do completely agree that
there should be limits on it
um you know there's speech that that
directly leads to violence and bad
behavior and I think it's perfectly
sensible to restrain that kind of speech
it's a much more down-to-earth practical
set of considerations that come into
line and that makes sense now the I
think that the um worry here about
defining exactly where the line is this
goes back to what I said about the theme
of this AMA where I'm going to be
arguing in favor of
slight amounts of ambiguity and
imprecision
yes I I it is hard to draw the line
between speech that is truly dangerous
in in the sense of people are going to
get hurt if you let this person do this
versus speech that is just uncomfortable
and you don't like it okay you would
like to be able to draw that line very
clearly but you can't that doesn't mean
the line isn't worth drawing and you
know in some sense there's two things to
say about this and they're both slightly
tangential but maybe uh Illuminating
remember the podcast we did with t nwen
where he talks about the seductive
nature of clarity the reason why so many
people like games which is fine but also
why they like conspiracy theories which
is bad is because of the false sense of
clarity right a game has rules and you
know what they are you know what's right
and what's wrong what's doable and
what's not doable a conspiracy theory
explains everything you know you you're
no longer stuck saying I don't know why
that's the case you're like no here it
is the conspiracy made it true that is a
very seductive property for explanations
to have but that doesn't make it right
and sometimes the best explanation we
have is not perfectly clear there's some
fuzzy boundaries and that's not a flaw
this is just a necessary aspect of
certain kinds of explanation you know
the standard thing is if you have some
high level emergent phenomenon something
like a chair right okay everyone agrees
that the thing I'm sitting on right now
is a chair where you to see the object
I'm sitting on right now you would all
agree it is a chair now if I remove an
atom from it
is it still a chair yeah you would not
even notice that I removed I probably
have removed Adam from it just by like
rubbing my fingers on it okay you don't
know but if I keep removing atoms one by
one eventually I will get to a point
where it is no longer a chair certainly
when I get down to one atom it is no
longer a chair right okay well if you
believe all that perfectly reasonable
stuff which you should believe tell me
precisely how many atoms I have to
remove to make it no longer a chair
you can't because there's no such thing
as the precise number of atoms it
becomes less and less chair-like but
there's no hard bright line between when
it's a chair and when it's not and the
point is that's okay
just because you can't draw a hard
bright line doesn't mean the concept of
chair is not useful the boundary between
chair and not chair might be approximate
and fuzzy and maybe some people draw it
in different places but it's still worth
drawing because the concept of a chair
gives you some handle on what happens in
the real world when I tell you I'm
sitting on a chair rather than a sofa or
on the floor you know something you
didn't know before I gave you useful
information
and that's that's a trivial example in
the world of physical objects but the
same thing is going to be true in Worlds
of politics and culture and things like
that there'll be a lot of principles
that are sensible to follow even though
you can't draw the lines for them
exactly this is something you have to
live with and do the hard work you know
don't demand Clarity where Clarity is
not available to be had
noble gas says what are some ways to
wrap our minds around the infinite
regress problem as it pertains to the
origin of the universe it seems like an
intractable problem because it's always
possible to ask what came before that if
the current answer is that we just don't
know is it possible to say what you
think an answer might look like
so I there is no such thing as the
infinite regress problem that is just
not a problem so I presume what you mean
by this is that if our universe is
eternal to the past and future then if
you give in to the everyday temptation
of explaining current events in terms of
events that happened before which is a
very sensible thing to do in the in the
everyday macroscopic world right causes
precede effects as as we all know but
you can't extend that principle of
causing causes preceding effects to
fundamental physics or to cosmology they
just don't apply the laws of physics
aren't like that the laws of physics are
not causes and then effects the laws of
physics are here's a pattern
LaPlace pointed this out if you have
data that tells you what's going on in
the universe at One Moment In Time you
can push it forward or backward and
explain either the past or the future if
your laplace's demon none of us is
laplace's demon but the laws of physics
are laplace's demon they know how to do
this so there's no infinite regress
problem because there's no principle
that says I must explain the conditions
at One Moment In terms of previous
moments
if there's infinite Universe there's an
eternal universe that goes from past
Infinity to plus infinity there's no
initial time there's no place from which
the universe came it was just always
there and that's it that's the fact it's
always a mistake to too quickly extend
the kinds of reasoning you do in your
kitchen and your everyday life to
fundamental questions about cosmology
and the universe
crafter Luca says can you explain what
the main disagreements are that cause
some people to believe quantum
entanglement is local versus non-local
and is it correct to say that within
many worlds quantum mechanics is
entirely local so I think I I think my
point of view on this is not exactly
standard I think the quantum
entanglement is simply non-local full
stop 100 percent
um now there are people who believe in
many worlds and will give you as a
reason why that it seems local
um and the way that they would say
something like that is that there are
branches and the things that are
observed on any one branch or purely
local phenomena but I think that's you
know number one it's a little bit of a
fast dance to Define very carefully what
do you mean by local et cetera there's
certainly non-local correlations in epr
pairs and things like that but more
fundamentally
I don't think that locality is a big
deal you know I think that the whole
discourse about locality the idea that
the world is made of things with
locations in space and time is just
completely overturned by quantum
mechanics wave functions are not local
you cannot decompose a wave function
into the wave function here and the wave
function there the wave function is a
function of every possible configuration
of everything in the universe all at
once
space emerges from the wave function not
the wave function lives in space so
there's no reason to expect locality at
all so my attitude is a huge amount of
effort and brain work in quantum
mechanics and foundations of quantum
mechanics is put into how can we live
with the non-locality of quantum
mechanics whereas my attitude is exactly
the flip side of that why is the
universe local at all
quantum mechanics isn't local quantum
mechanics is wildly non-local but yet
locality works pretty well in our
universe and of course this becomes even
more Vivid when you have quantum gravity
in quantum gravity if you imagine you
know integrating over all possible
space-time geometries it seems even less
likely that the Universe would look
local at all but it does to a very good
approximation so I think that the
question the puzzle is the other way
around why do things look local at all
not how do we learn to live with
non-locality
Alexandra Bates asks do you think the
U.S Constitution was a good basis for a
democracy at the time of its writing do
you think it remains a good basis for
today's industrial technologically
advanced U.S
yeah I think it's a great question this
is something that we really need to be
thinking about because on the one hand
yes I think the US Constitution was
honestly it was amazingly good for its
time I mean you think about the people
who were sitting down to write that
Constitution and you know the expertise
they had the United States got really
really lucky with people who were both
very smart and very well intentioned
they didn't all agree with each other
just you know go to watch Hamilton the
musical if you if you want to see how
people didn't always agree with each
other
um but they worked out compromises and
it actually was in many ways a very
sensible system but of course it's not
perfect and of course the flaws that it
might have had from the beginning might
get worse and worse as the society
changes conditions change the conditions
in the country change right
um so on the one hand I think that it
would be absolutely possible to sit down
from scratch and write a new
constitution for the United States that
would be much better than the one we
have right now on the other hand I have
very low Credence that that would
actually happen if we tried you know
some person or some other very smart set
of people might be able to do it but
given the current political climate if
we actually tried to get popular
support for a new constitution I bet it
would turn out to be a disaster so I
still think that even though the
Constitution has its problems we should
fix them through the existing mechanism
of amending the Constitution even that's
going to be really really hard to do
because people disagree on how to do it
but I'm not in favor of a wholesale
overturn of uh of what the Constitution
is now there is a question so I forget
whether I wanted to talk about this here
or yeah I mean maybe this let me ask the
next question but we'll feed into
Alexander's question also so Vladimir
belich says you and hopefully most of
most of us listeners are strongly in
favor of democracy and want it to be
preserved however as a thought
experiment could you come up with some
genuinely reasonable arguments against
democracy arguments that you personally
would find reasonable
um so yeah I don't think it's very
difficult to find arguments against
democracy you know I don't think that
there's a situation it's even close to
being the case that all the arguments
are on in democracy's favor democracy
has its problems you know one very
obvious problem is instability you know
a democracy only works if people buy in
to the idea that there should be a
democracy and this is one of the reasons
why we're in trouble right now because
increasingly we don't here in the United
States people just don't buy in to the
idea of democracy now they might say
they buy into the idea of democracy or
they might not I mean some will just be
explicitly against it but I think a lot
of people hear the word democracy and
say yes that means that I can vote for
something and if I get most people to
vote on my side then I win and it gets
implemented
but there's another part of democracy
that is equally important maybe more
important which is that if you lose you
have to live with it right that's the
part that matters it's not if I win I
get what I want it's if I lose I still
have to put up with it democracy is
about living with people you disagree
with and the reason why it is and this
is sort of another issue with democracy
other than
um instability is that
we have to take a whole bunch of people
who agree on some things and disagree on
other things and imagine that among the
set of things they agree on are the
basic principles of democracy including
going along when you lose and to find
exactly that set of people that agree on
enough to get along but still can
disagree on other things is a tricky
line to draw and so the instability
problem is that
if you get too many people who don't
like democracy then in a democracy they
can end it and there's almost no
solution for that problem I mean if that
actually happens it's essentially too
late right
um the only solutions to prevent it from
happening to make sure that most people
are on the side of democracy and to
really educate them and convince them
that they should be and that's a
non-trivial task which I think maybe we
take for granted a little bit
um there's a more basic problem with
democracy and that I think is the first
issue that a lot of people come up with
which is that it's putting equal voice
in principle of course we know that in a
world with inequalities is not actually
true but in principle every person every
voting citizen has an equal voice right
has an equal number of votes
but not every citizen is equally smart
or equally uh in possession of expertise
about difficult issues ETC right so
there's sort of a technocratic
meritocratic
um point of view which says well we
should give expert people smart people
talented people more of a voice than the
average person and I don't think that's
right but I get it I mean it it if you
think of democracy as sort of a way to
solve some science problem or technology
problem or even you know social
engineering problem then maybe yes maybe
that's what you would want to do but the
real reason why people have equal voices
in democracy are not because they're
equally smart but because we want all of
their values and interests to be
represented
so even if someone is not an expert on
climate change or whatever we want to be
able to give them the right to say I
want this to happen I want to protect my
values my interests
game theorists will tell you that this
is just asking for trouble in some way
because there's a tragedy of the commons
people are not going to sacrifice their
own personal well-being just for the
sake of the greater good all the time
and that's an issue and we need to worry
about it so but I nevertheless think
that it's better than the Alternatives
um and let me and this goes back to
Alexander's question about the
industrial technologically advanced us I
think it is a more subtle question about
democracy which is whether it is
compatible with modern technological
connected Society
I think it is I don't be too alarmist
about it I think it can be but when we
did write down these constitutions 200
years ago or 100 years ago in other
countries
um the world was a different place you
know we talked to each other in
different ways the information flow the
news sources were different
and countries were smaller right you
know even if you thought you know if you
were a farmer in rural West Virginia you
might not have felt even years ago very
connected what was going on in
Washington DC but proportionally you had
a bigger voice right because there were
just fewer people in the country so when
you have a country with hundreds of
millions of people or billions of people
in some countries
um
every individual vote doesn't count that
much right and the the reason why I'm
relating this to technology is as as
Daniels pointed out right in my
interview with them about uh everything
everywhere all at once in the Multiverse
the what technology is giving us is a
taste for the Multiverse because we can
look at other people's lives we can see
what's going on through whether it's
Instagram or Tick Tock or TV shows or
whatever
um the fact that other people are living
very different lives than us is much
more Vivid and accessible than it used
to be without giving us much more
ability to live those lives ourselves
right we can't all be Paris Hilton or
the Kardashians or whatever most of us
don't want to be but some of us do and
what all this gets to in some not very
well-defined way is a worry that
technology increases our alienation
as citizens of a democracy our feeling
that we can't have a voice we can't have
an impact on what happens the government
is this huge remote thing
um and there's a feeling of
powerlessness that comes with this and I
think that this explains a lot of the
rise of populism in the United States
and elsewhere you know a lot of people's
willingness to vote for clearly
anti-democratic figures because they
think that even if this person isn't
very Democratic at least they're they're
standing up for me right that's the
feeling I don't think it's true but the
feeling is something like that and so it
provides an opening for anti-democratic
forces to say I will act in your
interests in a way that this vast
bureaucracy that is elected through many
levels etc etc is no longer responsive
to your needs
and part of that does come from Pure
size but part of it also comes from
technology and part of it also comes
from our choice over the last half
century here in the U.S to put up with
way more inequality uh in some sense
than we used to have so it's not a fake
feeling that people are being ignored
they really are there there's a an
uncomfortable number of people who are
living lives that are less well off than
their previous generations did and
that's not what we were brought up to
believe so I think there's a complicated
combination of factors that are putting
democracy in trouble and some of them
are curable
some of them uh I don't know but anyway
I ended up worrying about the fate of
democracy rather than giving you
arguments against it but
ultimately you know there are arguments
against it Vladimir um expertise could
be big bigger in a non-democratic
um Society it might be more compatible
with modern technology it might be more
stable and finally it could act faster
right I mean this was a worry
not a worry but an argument people made
at the beginning of the pandemic which
was that a functioning dictatorship
could just implement
measures to fight against the
encroaching epidemic much more
effectively than a democracy could where
there's all these babbling voices and
there's inertia and things move slowly
and it's true that a dictatorship can
move much more quickly but the thing is
it doesn't always move in the right
direction so again I I'm referencing old
podcast episodes but with Henry Farrell
we talked about how democracy is
actually a pretty good problem-solving
mechanism and I think we're seeing that
uh in China and other places now where
policies are being implemented which are
two Draconian to fight the pandemic and
that are making things worse off overall
so
democracy is not perfect at pres at
solving these problems but I do think
it's better than all the Alternatives
that's where I would come down
okay where are we Anita tomasik says how
much Credence do you give to the concept
of boltzmanian immorality
particularly do human
do those human brain-like fluctuations
called boltzmann brains last long enough
to give rise to any form of
self-consciousness at all so Anita I'm
not sure whether there was a typo and if
you meant boltzmanian immortality but
you wrote immorality which I kind of
like so I left it in and actually I
don't know exactly what either one of
those Concepts would be
um but I think that it's a good
opportunity to clarify some aspects of
these boltzmann brain fluctuations
so the idea is that if you live in a
world where there are all sorts of
random fluctuations lasting forever okay
you need both those conditions to hold
if you live in a world without
fluctuations or in a world that doesn't
last forever the whole argument goes out
the window and both those are plausible
possibilities we don't know if these
fluctuations exist but if they do you
tell me some condition on some local
collection of matter okay so that
condition be whatever you want you can
say I would like to have at least one
kilogram of mass within a cubic
kilometer that's a condition or you can
say I would like to have a planet with
water oceans that's another condition or
you could say I would like to have a
conscious creature or you could say I
would like to have exactly me a person
that looks just like me with exactly my
thoughts and and and beliefs about the
world whatever condition you want okay
the in that fluctuating universe that
lasts eternally the that condition will
most often be achieved by waiting for a
random fluctuation to bring that
condition into existence not by having
what we call a thermodynamically
sensible Evolution from the low entropy
initial State like our big bang to today
okay so when you ask a question like do
boltzmann brains last long enough dot
dot dot well some of them do some of
them don't most of them don't but some
of them will and you're you ask there's
two different kinds of questions you can
ask one is in the set of all
fluctuations what will most of them be
like and that's kind of how you're
phrasing the question but the worry the
problem of this uh scenario doesn't come
from that it comes from asking the other
question the other way given some
conditions
are they likely to be random
fluctuations or is it likely to be
thermodynamically sensible and again
almost always whatever conditions you
want to put long-lived big smart
handsome moral immoral whatever whatever
conditions you want to put in that
randomly fluctuating Universe things
like that are most likely to arise as
random fluctuations that is not to say
that most random fluctuations will be
like that but most things like that will
be random fluctuations therefore from
Ever from whatever question you have
answer it in that basis I would say
flying waffle says I don't have an
actual question today but I asked
gpt3 which for those of you who've been
hiding from the Internet is an AI
program that is uh has read everything
in the world and and constructs
sentences and tell stories in the basis
of prompts that you give it so flying
waffle says I asked gpt3 to write a
Haiku in the style of Sean Carroll and
here are some of its best answers and
there's a whole bunch of answers I'm not
going to read all of them but just to
give you a flavor the very first one is
he's a theoretical physicist and he
writes about science and math he's also
pretty funny
so I love this as an example because
it's a wonderful example of how things
like GPT are nowhere near conscious or
even sensible or even all that smart
because not only is this Haiku not that
good it is nowhere near being a haiku
almost everyone knows who's heard of the
concept of a haiku that it's a little
three-line poem five syllables seven
syllables five syllables okay so clearly
what GPT 3 figured out is that it's a
three-line poem that's all it knows it
didn't get the syllable thing maybe it
doesn't know what a syllable is it
doesn't know anything at all it's doing
is doing correlations between different
pre-existing texts so this is not five
seven five so it's not a haiku even in
the dumbest sense but what many people
who don't get deeply into Haiku don't
realize is that there are more rules
about Haiku than that not every poem
that is five seven five counts as a
haiku by the strict original definition
uh it's supposed to be specifically
about the seasons or at least have
seasons in the sense of winter spring
summer fall as a theme of the poem and
there's also like a technical
requirement that I'm not going to say
exactly right but there has to be a
certain kind of Punchy impact word
usually near the very end of the Haiku
that kind of switch kind of turns twists
the meaning or what you were expecting
or something like that you know that's a
a little you know piece of vibrancy
right at the end of the Haiku that gives
this short kind of poem it's life and I
don't know maybe gpt3 thought that funny
was that kind of word but I think by
most of our standards it doesn't really
qualify
if you want to read the other poems uh
please check out on patreon and if
you're not a patreon supporter this
would be a good motivation you want to
read these other gpt3 haikus let me tell
you
Chris asks what would you say are the
starting points for your worldview
philosophy science that are themselves
not based on something else and how do
you justify these as the most
self-consistent set of hypotheses or
something else
so yeah as I said before it's more about
self-consistency than about
foundationalism you know I talk about
this in the big picture there was always
this idea back in many years ago in
philosophy that we would find
in unimpeachable truths right we would
found find foundational
axioms postulates whatever you want to
call them on the basis of which you
could then just build up a whole set of
completely true absolutely believable
rigorously demonstrated statements and
that's just not how the world works you
know you can do it in math you can say
all right here are some axioms we're
going to derive the implications of
these axioms but in physics or in
science you want to know whether the
axioms are true you want to choose the
axioms or the foundational principles
that actually accurately describe the
world and that process is never a
hundred percent reliable there's always
some fuzziness there again that's the
theme of this AMA so that's okay so I I
don't know I had not even tried really
to axiomatize uh my own world view in
any way off the top of my head I would
say the two things that I kind of start
with are the idea that the world is
intelligible in other words that there
are patterns out there there are ways to
make sense of what happens in the world
is not all completely random nonsensical
meaningless
um and the other is that our sense data
or input tells us something true about
the world now that's a trickier one
because what it tells us is clearly not
the unvarnished truth and it's really
not the whole truth but I'm imagining
that it is not completely false either
that we're not being tricked by an evil
demon or anything like that and so we
try to build up systems of understanding
how the world Works based from these
starting points and see how it goes and
it's never perfect certainty that we
achieve but it's a way of getting
through the world and so it's more of a
pragmatic slash practical justification
it's what works by its own light it's a
self-contestant self-consistent set of
idea
um that does what it aims to do that's
why I think that the basic scientific
hypothetical inductive model works
pretty well
Joey says I've been thinking that our
society is really bad for people with
serious mental illnesses such as
schizophrenia as we believe in people
are rational and give them a degree of
self-agency
sorry as in we believe people are
rational and give them a degree of
self-agency but for people who behave
irrationally many of our social safety
nets break down other than a benevolent
overload Lord what do you think would
make the world better
well you know I don't this is not one of
those things where I have a clear
program to advocate for or anything like
that but I agree
um that we have issues in society with
people with serious mental illnesses but
this is kind of just I think part of a
set of problems we have in our society
about people who are not well off who
are not
empowered in various ways to make a
healthy life life for themselves
um we do have this idea and again it's a
it's an important idea even though it's
a fuzzy one that some people are
responsible that they can decide for
themselves that they can vote they can
drive cars or whatever and they can
basically form their own lives up to the
constraints of the real world in which
they live and other people are not
responsible they must be taken care of
um they're not sort of to be held
responsible or blameful for things that
they do because of either mental illness
or they're too young or whatever and and
as as I said before this these
categories make sense they work and
they're important even if we cannot uh
Define them directly I do think about
helping people who are mentally ill
that we can do a much better job you
know like I came from Los Angeles where
there's a lot of homeless people around
I believe there's also lots of homeless
people here in Baltimore many of them
are either drug addicts or mentally ill
in some way and I would like to help
them in some way I think that as a
society we're certainly wealthy and
powerful enough to give everyone a home
to not let there be homeless people and
we're making a choice as a society to
let this issue continue because we don't
care that much and I think we should
care more what should I actually do
about it at a practical political level
I don't know I am not uh I'm not that
optimistic that way and I really don't
have anything to offer but again happy
to listen to other people's ideas
Rob Butler says if macroscopic objects
behave classically where does the
quantum world end of the macroscopic
world begin if these two descriptions
small Quantum and large classical act so
differently in our reality why do we
need a unifying Theory well we don't
need unifying Theory theory for
classical and Quantum because we have
one it's called quantum mechanics
classical mechanics is a limit of
quantum mechanics so that's been
completely unified uh I shouldn't I
that's a little bit too glib
um the set of situations under which
objects in the world are well
approximated by the classical limit is a
little bit tricky there's still a little
bit of work to be done there to make
that perfectly clear
that's part of what I did in my paper
not too long ago with ashmeet saying on
Quantum myriology how is it possible to
divide up the quantum world into
classical systems plus environments but
still
um there's no quest to unify classical
mechanics and quantum mechanics
classical mechanics is a proper subset
of quantum mechanics
um so but one other thing to say about
that is that people sometimes say you
know quantum mechanics begins to be
relevant when systems are small or
something like that and that's not
exactly precisely rigorously right the
right thing to say is quantum mechanics
is always true
but there is also a subset of
circumstances under which classical
mechanics is a good approximation and
there's a subset of circumstances under
which classical mechanics is not a good
approximation and you need to invoke
those parts of quantum mechanics that
are not present in the classical limit
that's really what we mean when we say
that quantum mechanics becomes important
in the small scale microscopic world
Brent Meeker says in the solo episode on
finding gravity within quantum mechanics
mindscape 63. you speculated that there
are only finite finite many degrees of
freedom in a given volume wouldn't this
imply that they're also only finitely
many possible States and so there will
be a smallest non-zero probability of
any possible event
so
um no that's not quite right so yes to
the first half of that sentence but not
to the second half so finitely many
possible States right that is in fact
what is
implied by imagining only finite number
of degrees of freedom but think about
how quantum mechanics Works states are
vectors okay even if you only have two
states like a spin could be spin up or
spin down you also have superpositions
of spin up and spin down and that
superposition is some complex number
times spin up plus some complex number
times spin down and the probability of
observing spin up or spin down is the
square of that complex number now that
complex number can be anything between
zero and one it can be arbitrarily close
to one or arbitrarily close to zero that
has nothing to do with the number of
states so the probability can be as
small as you want Even though there's
only two states and the same thing is
true if you have many more than two but
still some finite number
Greg says an omniscient super being
gives you one and only one question
about the true physical nature of the
universe which they will answer
correctly but it has to be a yes or no
question you know the answer will be
correct and absolutely true what do you
ask so I'm going to weasel out of this
question a little bit I'm not going to
answer it directly because what I want
to say is I kind of don't think that
these questions are the best way of
thinking about knowledge or the Quest
for knowledge because
there's always this question of what
would you ask what one question would
you have uh answered by God or whatever
about physics and so forth but the thing
is without knowing how the world works
at the fundamental level we don't even
know which questions to ask
you know if Isaac Newton had been asked
that question he might have had some
ideas about what he wanted to know but
he wasn't going to discover quantum
mechanics or general relativity by
asking one question of God okay even if
God was in an answerable mood uh because
he doesn't know what to ask what what is
the issue to be addressed and I think
the same thing is true like if our goal
is I want to know the once and for all
laws of physics right that is a goal
that I have or How the Universe began
um but if I ask the question how the
universe began
presumably in the that would require a
long elaborate discussion of the true
physical theory of the universe and what
it was actually implying about the
moment of the beginning of the universe
if there indeed was any such moment so
it just doesn't take the form of a yes
or no question
um so anyway I I don't think that
that this this Oracle kind of model
where you imagine asking a question and
getting a once and for all reliable
answer is a very good one to think about
in the case of science however just to
sort of try to do my best it would be
nice to know whether the universe lasted
forever or not whether it had a
beginning or not but again I foresee
that the answer would be well maybe time
is not fundamental so it's not even a
yes or no question that's why I think
that these these questions are sort of
hard to imagine getting useful answers
to
Paul torreck says and you talk on the
Arrow of time in causal networks you say
if you want to draw a causal Network
arrows that only go one way in time you
only get right answers drawing them from
past to Future
that's a pretty big if if there's more
to say what if someone doesn't want to
do that and then in parentheses I
simplified and hopefully not
oversimplified the quote to save time so
maybe you anticipated this being the
answer but you did oversimplify the
quote sorry about that the quote in the
talk was some I forget exactly it myself
but the point of it was saying not if
you want to have arrows that only go one
way in time but if you want to have
arrows that only go from one moment to
the subsequent or preceding moment in
other words if you don't want the arrows
in your causal diagram of the whole
history of the universe to spread out
over all moments of time
so the thing about this whole causal
network uh analysis and and the project
that I'm trying to do connecting that to
fundamental physics is that there are no
arrows of the level of fundamental
physics okay there's just a pattern that
is unbreakable and perfectly reversible
from past future according to our best
current understanding the arrows and
causality only come about in the
macroscopic emergent world they're a
useful approximation okay so it's a
hundred percent legitimate for me to ask
for features of my useful approximation
that are useful to me and it is possible
according to the rules of the game to
draw causal arrows from one moment of
time to the next moment of time but also
in a network that involves arrows you
know from The Big Bang to that moment
that do not pass through all the
subsequent moments but that's kind of
useless that's not really what I'm
looking for you know it it's like saying
I can explain the any effect At All by
saying the cause of it is the initial
conditions of the universe plus the laws
of physics but it's even less useful
than that because I'm saying I can
explain what happens next by what
happens now plus independently what's
happening at the Big Bang it's just not
a very useful set of explanations the
nice thing is that the way the laws of
physics work
is that I don't have to have causal net
worth coming from The Big Bang or from
the future or anything like that I can
invent a sensible causal Network where
the arrows just go from one moment of
time to the next but I can only do that
going from one moment to the next future
moment not to the previous moment in the
past and that's a non-trivial statement
Patricia Paulson says I watched your
lectures on Dark Matter dark energy from
the Great Courses they were recorded in
2007 before the LHC was operational and
the Higgs was discovered I believe you
said something like how you hoped in
five years or so there would be some big
discoveries regarding Dark Matter uh and
dark energy 15 years later would you
have lots more discoveries to expound
upon in a new series of lectures or
would it be pretty much the same as
2007. so my guess is I don't remember
exactly what I said
um I'm certainly willing to believe that
I said I was hopeful in five years to
get big discoveries regarding dark
matter because I was hopeful of that in
2007. it has not turned out to be true
my hopes were not fulfilled I doubt that
I said that there would be big
discoveries regarding Dark Energy
because I think that the discovery in
1998 that the universe is accelerating
is perfectly well explained by the
cosmological constant and if that's true
there are no more empirical discoveries
to be made about that we need better
Theory to explain the value of the
cosmodial constant but what the
cosmological constant is is perfectly
well understood we don't need to do more
if the dark energy were something
dynamical uh were not just a
cosmological constant then there would
be more discoveries to come but I think
that those are actually unlikely
whereas with dark matter we don't know
what it is we don't have a
overwhelmingly plausible candidate like
we do for Dark Energy so there I was
hopeful that we would discover something
and five years was a reasonable sort of
50 50 Credence but we turned out on the
sad side of the 50 50. and that's you
know it's it's part of a problem that is
plaguing all the fundamental physics
whether it's particle physics cosmology
or whatever we haven't had any new truly
surprising discoveries so the only
updates really for the 2007 lectures
would be some details about astrophysics
we know a little certainly more about
large-scale structure and surveys and so
forth we discovered the Higgs boson 10
years ago 10 years ago as I'm recording
this and so that would be something to
note but it hasn't really fed in in any
direct way to knowing what the dark
matter is or the dark energy and so we
have no direct evidence for what the
dark matter is but again that's
something that could come within the
next five years but I'm less
uh likely to predict that now now so in
2007 I was happy to give a 50 chance
that something good would happen in the
next five years but that doesn't mean
that there's still a 50 chance that
something will happen in the next five
years or the next five years because in
the space of all possible theories there
is a you know certain amount of phase
space for it's going to take a really
long time maybe forever before you get
direct evidence about the dark matter
and that Credence has grown since 2007.
I still think that it's likely that in
the next I don't know
um 20 years let's say it becomes harder
and harder to push our experimental
limits right it's more technology
because as the limits get further away
it's harder to get there but I'm still
hopeful that in my lifetime we will find
some direct evidence for Dark Matter uh
but I could be wrong you never know
Phil says quantum mechanics claims that
one cannot predict with certainty when a
radioactive atom will Decay or even give
even even given a complete understanding
of the laws of physics as well as
complete knowledge of the state of the
universe how can quantum mechanics make
this claim given that we don't yet have
a complete understanding of the laws of
physics nor a complete knowledge of the
state of the universe
well it's the difference between the
claim being made by quantum mechanics
and the claim being made by reality so
in quantum mechanics we know the laws of
physics governing quantum mechanics I
mean it's presumed that you're talking
about quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics is a well-defined theory and
it says here are the laws of physics you
don't have to believe them they might
not be right but they're the laws that
are the quantum laws and so according to
the rules of quantum mechanics you
cannot predict the certainty when a
radioactive atom will Decay so if we
discover some way in the future that we
can predict with certainty when a
radioactive atom will Decay it will be
because quantum mechanics is wrong not
because we didn't understand what
quantum mechanics was saying
Joelle Curtis says where do you stand on
the merits of the rubber sheet analogy
to illustrate space-time curvature I see
a lot of people denigrate the analogy
but I think it does a fair job of
striking a balance between making the
idea accessible and not sending enough
people away with entirely the wrong idea
or start not sending people away with
entirely the wrong idea yeah I think
it's fine the rubber sheet analogy uh I
think you know analogies are an
important part of explaining scientific
Concepts some analogies are better than
others every analogy has the problem
that
parts of the analogy are supposed to
tell you something about the thing being
analogized and parts are supposed to be
ignored okay so when you have the rubber
sheet analogy you like put a bowling
ball in a rubber sheet and you say look
the rubber is now being warped and
curved and that's kind of like the ball
is warping space time the problem with
that is that you're using the force of
gravity to pull down the ball and that's
warping the sheet so there's a
directionality downward none of that is
true in space time where the Earth or
the Sun just sits there and warp the
space time around it and there's no
gravity pulling them down it's their
warping that is gravity so there are
aspects of the analogy that are not
actually Illuminating real features of
the world that's okay as long as you get
that as long as you explain that as part
of the analogy there are other analogies
which I don't like because it is very
difficult to let go of the misleading
parts of the analogy so I'm not a big
fan of the rubber balloon analogy for
the expansion of the unit Universe which
is a little bit different than the
rubber sheet analogy for the curvature
of space-time and the reason why the
balloon analogy has two things you take
a two things wrong with it you take a
balloon you put some dots on it you blow
it up and you see that the balloon is
expanding the dots are moving apart from
each other that's kind of like the
expansion of the universe and the dots
or galaxies right that's the analogy two
very big problems with that one is that
the dots grow when the balloon grows and
galaxies do not grow with the expansion
of the universe they just get further
apart so that's false and even worse the
balloon has an inside and an outside
the balloon is expanding into the space
around it and so no matter how hard you
try when you use that analogy you're
giving people the impression that the
universe is expanding into something and
it's not
so to me even though it's a fine analogy
in the sense that it plays by the rules
some aspects are Illuminating aspects of
the thing being analogized and some are
not it's a bad analogy because it's
really hard to undo the damage of the in
applicable aspects of the analogy
whereas the rubber sheet analogy for
space-time curvature I think is pretty
clear to explain to people what aspects
are important and which ones are not
Walter White asks a priority question
does the block Universe imply eternal
life or immortality in any sense and if
yes does it mean our life repeats itself
over and over again since the world
lines are a finite length I couldn't
imagine any other way in which we live
forever or am I misunderstanding the
concept so I think I'm gonna have to
apologize Walter I know this is a
priority question but I don't get it
I I so the answer is no the block
Universe does not imply eternal life in
any sense at all so I don't know why it
would
the block Universe just means we treat
every moment of time as being equally
real so an important caveat there is
that because we live in time people tend
to think people tend to attach an extra
word of real at the same time or real
simultaneously or something like that
that's not what the block universe is
saying different moments of time are
real at different moments of time
they're just equally real so there's no
immortality immortality means you live
through all the moments of time and in
the block Universe you don't so there's
no reason at all I think to to connect
those two ideas
Eric dovigi says possibly a dumb
question but I feel this is the same
zone for that yes it is I might not
answer it but you're certainly welcome
to ask any dumb questions why do objects
Bend space-time I get that they do but I
mean why
so I understand you know and there's two
kind of approaches to answering a
question like this one is just because
that's what the laws of physics say and
that's a perfectly legitimate answer
it's not wrong you know you can imagine
alternate worlds other possible worlds
where objects did not curb space time so
we happen to live in a world where
objects curve space time according laws
of physics that's a perfectly legitimate
answer there's another level of answer
which sort of makes some assumptions and
then builds conclusions on top of those
assumptions so the best way to do it is
something that is is probably through
like the action principle okay the
action principle says that in ordinary
classical mechanics you have some
trajectory for a ball rolling down a
hill or a planet going around the Sun it
has a quantity you can Define called the
action which has to do with the kinetic
energy minus the potential energy over
the path as a whole okay and so
basically you can say why do planet
let's orbit the Sun and ellipses well
you could say it's because of an inverse
Square law of force but alternatively
you could say that is the path that
minimizes the action and the action is a
competition between trying to well you
want to minimize the action the action
is kinetic energy minus potential energy
so you want small kinetic energy but
large potential energy right and so you
might say well small kinetic energy just
don't move but you want to actually do
the trajectory that starts somewhere and
ends somewhere so you have to move a
little bit so you need some kinetic
energy and then you want to balance that
with potential energy and the real
motion around an ellipse is what does
that there's a similar line of reasoning
for curved space time that was invented
by Hilbert in consultation with Einstein
there's a way of thinking about the
action for space time and basically
there's a contribution to the action
from matter from stuff okay from energy
and momentum and there's another
contribution from the curvature of of
space-time and you want to minimize the
overall amount of action and the way to
do that is to have space time curve a
little bit in response to the energy and
momentum inside now everything I just
said there is true unless I made a
mistake which is always possible
um but the does it explain why matter
curve space time I don't know it depends
I mean why is the action principle true
why does the action take that form
doesn't explain any of those things
we're just assuming from the start that
they're that they're true so whether
that's satisfying to you or not I am
ill-equipped to judge
Gary Upshaw says throughout human
history humans have accessed new forms
of energy sources animal muscle would
win coal oil Etc nuclear fission so
anyway I'm not going to read the whole
question because it's long remember
shorter questions are the ones that get
answered but I'm going to just
paraphrase this one Gary is saying we're
soon going to invent nuclear fusion have
a huge amount of energy new energy
sources are generally associated with uh
depleting the resources of the planet
and sort of doing environmental
catastrophes so are we worried that
Fusion is going to do that so I don't
think so I mean for two reasons number
one I'm not at all convinced that
nuclear fusion is imminent I would like
it to be I certainly hope it is but the
technological barriers are severe and
we've been trying to do it for a long
time and haven't yet so some caution is
in order the other one is I don't think
you can simply say that when we get new
energy phases human population has
increased and we've been accessing the
Earth's resources better it's a much
more complicated story than that so I
can certainly imagine that this
particular kind of new energy source
nuclear fusion would help us not deplete
other resources that the planet has we
don't need to dig for fossil fuels as
much if we have unlimited fusion power
right so I just think the question is a
little bit more complicated and you know
it might might give us new ways to do
damage to the planet but I don't think
that's a necessary or inevitable
consequence
Richard Graf says I'm 62 and aware of
the valuable perspective that comes with
those in later years however I've come
to believe that our nation would benefit
from an upper limit somewhere before 60
on the age a person can be elected a U.S
president Senator Etc
to continue to serve on the Supreme
Court or whatever what are your thoughts
on this idea so I don't love the idea
Richard I don't think that there should
be um age limits because I think that
some people who are older are perfectly
capable of being really good at these
jobs and some are not I would rather
judge people on their actual capacities
rather than their age or something like
that I do think that term limits for
Supreme Court Justices make a absolute
100 sense there's zero reason why
Supreme Court justices have lifetime
terms it really makes things worse
because in the current really Dopey
system that we have for choosing the
Supreme Court there is this huge
incentive for presidents and senators
to find ideologically compatible Supreme
Court Justices who are really young
because they're going to serve for the
rest of their lives if there was just a
term you know eight years or ten years
or whatever that you served on the
Supreme Court then that would be there'd
be no incentive to find young people you
would just try to find the best people
and that just makes enormously more
sense to me I mean there's no more
political Freedom that you have from
having a guaranteed lifetime term than
you do from having having a guaranteed
10-year term or whatever
um but I don't care what age you are at
that having said all that there is
absolutely a problem in the current U.S
system with a gerontocracy there are too
many of our leaders who are really old
especially in the Democratic Party by
the way Republican has a Republican
party has much more churn in its
leadership and a lot more young people
but the people leading the Democratic
party you've been around for decades now
and I don't think that's a healthy thing
any individual one person can be as old
as you like and still be very good at
their job but there's a tendency you
know with
the way that apportionment Works etc for
people to be elected into office
especially in the Senate and just keep
getting elected forever and that you
know why would they leave it's a cushy
job with a lot of perks so we end up
with really old people and that's not
necessarily good and I would like to
come up with ways to get uh to fix that
Mr Foo says priority question with the
with relation to many worlds do the
other worlds have an XYZ coordinate
within space or do they exist in other
locations that cannot be defined by
distance from Earth so no they do not
have an XYZ coordinate within space nor
do they have an existence in another
location at all you should not think of
the worlds as existing in some other
space as having location in any space at
all they exist simultaneously that's the
thing to say but they don't have
locations in Space the idea of location
in space is something that exists within
each World okay space is an emerging
concept inside the world it's not that
the worlds are embedded in some bigger
space
Graham Clark says in his book The Revolt
of the public Martin Guri talks a bit
about science and using climate science
as an example portrays the institution
as acting like a cartel defending its
researchers and findings against any
opposing views however valid and a peer
review process hopelessly inadequate in
a time of massive data sets and esoteric
research areas does any of this ring
true to you in your research areas or
elsewhere so I have to you know confess
I've not read the book
I know nothing about what gory is trying
to say so I cannot pretend to actually
be commenting on what Martin Gorey said
or the book
um I can't respond to the paraphrase
here in this question and for the most
part no this does not sound right it
sounds like a sort of overly alarmist
hot take rather than an actual nuanced
view of how science works there are
aspects of these critiques that
absolutely make sense I mean of course
scientists defend their own views like
most people do if they didn't want to
defend those views they would probably
have other views right I think that
scientists are more willing than many
sets of people to imagine alternative
views and to think about them especially
if you say defend finding against
opposing views however valid one of the
great things about science is that even
though scientists will defend their
views for a long time once an obviously
more valid view comes along they will
change their minds that's the one of the
Great things about science it's easiest
to do when the new view is backed up by
an experiment by data that's when people
will really change their minds very
rapidly but even a really knock down
theoretical argument will convince
people to change their minds what you
have very often is unconvincing
theoretical arguments that do not
convince people to change their minds
even if they might be right you know
because you can have an argument you
know like let's let's think about the
foundations of quantum mechanics let's
think about
uh spontaneous collapse theories no
actually forget about those yeah well
all right let's think about spontaneous
collapse theories versus many worlds
okay both of those have disadvantages
many worlds has the disadvantage that
there are many worlds and that it's a
very different metaphysical view of
reality than we ordinarily have and even
if that's perfectly fine I think it's
also fine to be methodologically
conservative and say look this is such a
huge leap from our ordinary way of
thinking that we should be cautious
about it whereas something like
spontaneous collapse theories you're
doing tremendous violence to the
Schrodinger equation which is a very
elegant equation by just sticking in
there some arbitrary random collapse
idea so there's always pluses and
minuses and different people will have
different feelings about which pluses
and minuses matter and which ones will
eventually be understood better so
that's disagreement that scientists just
put up with and it's not a matter of one
camp or the other not listening to
reason in it's just that they have
different very reasonable ideas about
what will eventually turn out to be the
case
um
peer review is certainly imperfect in
many ways but to call it hopelessly
inadequate is hopelessly wrong I mean
that's this just seems like cheap shots
rather than carefully thinking about how
science Works which makes me sad because
there are legitimate critiques about how
science works I think that it's
perfectly fair to think that scientists
will go too far in supporting the kinds
of research programs they approve of and
not far enough in allowing other
alternative research programs to
flourish that's something I've already
said earlier in the AMA I don't think
that climate science is an especially
good example because uh it's a it's an
unrepresentative example because of all
the political pressures around it and
those political pressures both convince
a whole bunch of people of really Dopey
things like the climate is not changing
or it's not because of human beings but
they also because science scientists
themselves are human
they introduce non-scientific
considerations into how scientists talk
about it the same thing is true for
evolutionary biology especially back in
the days when creationism was a big
worry a lot of evolutionary biologists
would not want to allow certain kinds of
critiques of evolutionary biology
because they opened the door to
creationism and I never went along with
that I'm like you know let in whatever
critiques you want if they're bad
critiques and respond to them and I
think that ideally in a perfect position
the same thing would be true for climate
science and it largely is but there is
some
um correctness to the worry that climate
scientists are I mean they know that the
climate is getting worse that it's
because of human beings and so they
really want to Stamp Out criticisms of
methodologies that get there even though
some of those criticisms might have a
point you know even if the overall
conclusion is not changed some of the
details might be up for
um critique in some interesting way so
there are are real critiques there but
anyway within the version that is
presented in this paraphrase I think
that that's just uh going way too far
and not an especially nuanced careful
Direction late night Linux says the
scientific method was devised by white
men same with math some people say this
makes them inherently biased and
possibly even racist is this something
that you've thought about
I haven't thought about it a lot but
also I don't know a lot of people who
say that so I think that there might be
people in the world who say things like
that but there are very few of them and
certainly not very influential ones it
is close to a critique that is made by
more people and that more influential
ones namely that science and math even
if they're perfectly objective have been
used in the cause of biased racist
points of view or social structures or
whatever and that's just true that's not
to say that the science or the math are
biased or racist they're just science
and math but they can be put to racist
or biased purposes they can be used
misused in that way and that's something
we should think about
um also it's not even true that they
were devised by white men they were a
lot of white men had very important
roles to play but a lot of people who
are not white or not men also had
important roles to play so I don't want
to silence them either
Joe Moskowitz says I was watching your
something deeply hidden talk at Google
and something jiggled loose in my brain
and many worlds suddenly seemed more
reasonable
the slide with the expression for the
dead and alive Schrodinger's cat
multiplied by the environment and the
Observer because of the universal wave
function seems to have been the exact
Tipping Point even though I've seen that
before I'm highly suspicious of 50 years
of my opinion shifting in a few seconds
any advice so I'd like this a question
because it's actually not a question
about quantum mechanics it's you thought
it was going to be a question about
quantum mechanics didn't you but it's a
question about changing your mind and
yeah I don't think you should be
suspicious I get why you're suspicious
that you had a point of view for a very
long time and it all seemed perfectly
sensible and you were going to stick to
it and suddenly you switched but what I
really think is that it's less sudden
than you imagine because I think that
when we have beliefs
when we have points of view or credences
or whatever we have sort of our
conscious level beliefs but there's a
lot going on beneath the surface and
it's an example
um Jennifer Willette my wife uh talks
about this in a talk that she gave in an
article she's written about a plateau
kind of effect when it comes to
um people's changing beliefs and it
comes from an example of when you cook
when you slow cook slow cook pulled pork
okay I mean it's not pulled when you're
cooking it you're cooking a pork
shoulder whatever low and slow over a
barbecue and if you do that and you put
a thermometer in there and you plot
temperature versus time what happens is
as you begin to cook over very low heat
the pork shoulder the temperature goes
up almost linearly and then it plateaus
okay it remains more or less constant
even though you're still heating it up
and then after a while the plateau stops
and it starts heating again and and pit
Masters Barbecue Masters know about this
and they know that what's actually going
on is when that Plateau hits the there's
been a transition where it is easier for
the pork shoulder to just expel Vapor
expel water vapor and lose heat that way
um or I suppose gain heat that way I'm
not sure what it's doing it's not it's
not gaining temperature but it's uh
rather than gaining temperature in the
pork it is instead expelling hot water
vapor into the barbecue pit and that's
bad because you want your pork shoulder
to be moist so when this when the
plateau first hits you open up the grill
wrap it in aluminum foil or whatever to
keep the moisture in and then put it
back
why am I saying all this because if the
only thing you knew was the temperature
if that's the only variable that you are
keeping track of you would say well the
temperature was going up and then it was
constant and then it started going up
again but beneath the surface something
is changing while the temperature is
constant there's another variable you
are not keeping track of the moisture
right the level of water content in the
pork shoulder so I think the same thing
happens all the time with our beliefs
which is that we think our beliefs are
constant but there's a subset a set of
sub beliefs is what I'm trying to say
lying beneath the surface that change
gradually you get more information you
put pieces of information together
slowly gradually it builds up and then
what it appears to you like is a sudden
phase transition right you're like oh
yesterday I believe this today I believe
this why do I have this sudden
transition I think that usually the
answer is because your mind has been
changing but in invisible ways in ways
that do not show up on the surface which
by the way
is why I think that there's a lot of
issues in involved with
studies of how to change people's minds
right because they work on short time
scales they will present something to
you and ask like have you changed your
mind right now and maybe the answer is
no but maybe that thing that's been
presented to you will Linger on for days
or months or years and have an effect on
you changing your mind years later which
the psychology experiment will never
capture so there's something to keep in
mind when we think about why people
believe things and how those beliefs
change
Simon Reynolds says have you ever tried
to enter a friendly wager with another
scientist and could you consider that as
a good way to help people consider their
positions more carefully
um yeah I absolutely have and and I
almost always win because I don't enter
into bets that I think that I have a
decent possibility of losing you never
know for sure of course everyone thinks
that but I don't enter into many 50 50
bets so um I I want to bet uh that some
people know about with Brian Schmidt who
was my office made in grad school and
later won the Nobel Prize for helping
lead the team to discover discover the
accelerating universe back when we were
both in grad school he was the cynical
Observer and I was the story-eyed
theorist and we bet about whether or not
astronomers in the next 20 years would
be able to measure the density parameter
of the universe because astronomers been
trying to measure the amount of matter
in the universe and it was hard and they
didn't get the answer that the theorist
predicted Etc now when Brian and his
friends discovered the acceleration of
the universe and therefore the dark
energy that fixed the problem then we
knew what the extra energy density of
the universe was so on the one hand I
won the bat because I said we would
figure it out and he said we never would
but he won the Nobel Prize so it's a
win-win bet really from all points of
view
P Walder says in your 2020 Royal
Institution on the Multiverse you
explained how linear tracks that appear
in Cloud Chambers only seem to infer a
particle-like cause rather than a
wave-like clause the talk was excellent
it helped clarify what can and can't be
known about the Multiverse but I'm still
confused about why there are linear
Cloud chamber tracks could you have
another go at explaining this phenomenon
sure actually I think that this is
something where
I guess as far as I recall I did not go
into detail about this in something
deeply hidden in my book
um but it's worth going into detail
maybe I I should have and I regret not
doing that this question of why if you
just saw the Schrodinger equation you
have a nucleus that decays
uh you can solve it for what the
radiating particle will look like with
the wave function of the radiating
particle will look like and roughly
speaking it's a spherical wave you know
the particle that is emitted is emitted
equally its wave function looks more or
less the same in every direction that's
not going to be exactly true but that's
a pretty good approximation but it's not
what you see when you measure it so you
do that inside a cloud chamber what do
you see a line not a big spherical Cloud
why do you see that well I mean you're
going to guess correctly the answer
right it's because of decoherence and
things like that so what happens is
there is a spherical wave function that
is produced
it moves out in every direction and if
you if you subscribe to the many worlds
way of talking about this stuff it
interacts and becomes entangled with the
particles around it in the cloud chamber
but the point is that as soon as it
interacts with one particle in the cloud
chamber then the universe splits right
into the part of the universe where it
interacted with that one particle and
the part where it didn't
and in the branch of the universe where
it interacted with that one particle the
rest of the wave function the rest of
the spherical
um sphere The Cloud of wave function
that was emitted from the nucleus the
rest of it is no longer there in that
Universe it's in the other universes
there's a one Universe where the
particle was not interacting with that
particular part of the cloud chamber and
then the rest of the wave function says
it did okay so in the branch where it
interacted with that particle and became
entangled the wave function of the
radiated particle is no longer spherical
now it is localized near the particle
that it interacted with okay because
that's where it hit it and so that
little wave packet now of the radiated
particle that interacted with the cloud
chamber keeps going in a straight line
and is no longer a sphere it's just a
little localized wave packet and then it
just keeps interacting with other
particles after the fact and and it
forms a line the rest of the wave
function which is now like a sphere
minus a little hole okay that keeps
interacting and if it interacts with one
particle in some other location then it
will again Branch the wave function into
a little wave packet moving in that
direction plus the rest of the universe
and so on and so on
so you get many many universes each one
of which has a each particle being
radiated describing a straight line or a
curved line if you're in a magnetic
field inside the cloud chamber so that's
why waves begin to look like particles
and quantum mechanics once you start
observing them
Daniel fox says I recently had a minor
stroke while running no apparent lasting
damage however no one can say exactly
what caused the occlusion it just seems
like a random thing without any of the
usual health or behavioral indicators
I've been a big ultra distance runner
for years and it's been a big part of my
identity the question is how would you
approach the decision of whether and to
what extent you would continue to run so
preface this by saying I'm not a doctor
I have a PhD but I'm not a medical
doctor I am not the one you should ask
this question too so there's a
methodological question here that I can
talk about but I'm not going to give
advice about how to deal with your
health the methodological question is it
sounds like the issue is that
something bad has happened right you had
a minor stroke while running and you
don't know whether it is associated with
the running or not so if you did know
right then there's still a question
because you say there's a probability a
risk of having a little stroke while I'm
running but I like running and running
has other good benefits and how do I
weigh that risk and that's a perfectly
legitimate set of questions to ask and I
don't exactly know what the right answer
is different people's judgments will be
different that's pretty that's
completely fine the difficulty I take it
in this question is that you don't even
know if the stroke had anything to do
with the running or if it was just
coincidental
um if you if you thought that there was
a serious possibility of having a stroke
then stop running there are other things
you can do
um but you're in this method
epistemological tricky position because
you don't know and that's really really
hard honestly this is all I have to say
um I do think that it makes sense to be
cautious
um to really do research about what are
the reasons why people have strokes and
do any of those reasons have to do with
running and yeah the best you can do in
in situations of uncertainty like this
is minimize your uncertainty there will
always be some uncertainty but you can
try to minimize it so you can say look
at all the data or you know hopefully
look at the data that has already been
analyzed by somebody else but do runners
have more Strokes
do people who run tend to have their
Strokes while running even if you can't
pinpoint a relationship causally in
yourself and your body you can at least
statistically look at the relationship
in other people's experiences and if you
find that yeah people who are distance
Runners tend to have more Strokes or
people who are prone to strokes and are
distance Runners are more in Greater
Jeopardy because of that then I think
it's reasonable to conclude that you
might be in more risk than you otherwise
would be and to take that seriously so I
guess the only thing I'm saying is even
in the absence of a direct mechanism to
explain where the danger is coming from
you can still use indirect methods to
see that there could be a danger there
and take it into account
Kathy Seeger says a question about
consciousness
referring to the Mind chat discussion
you participated in in May so by the way
mine chat not mindscape mind chat is a
uh podcast video podcast from Philip
Goff previous mindscape guest and Keith
Frankish and they're both
philosophers who care about
Consciousness and Philip of course is a
pan psychist and Keith is a physicalist
slash illusion Illusionist the way that
he likes to talk about Consciousness is
that it's just an illusion that's not my
preferred way of talking about it but in
fact push come to shop we're pretty
close on our points of view so the two
of them disagree with each other but
they do it in a friendly way and it's
worth uh listening to so I did a couple
of of episodes with them one just by
myself one with Barry lower who's a
philosopher at Rutgers anyway Kathy says
I'm not going along with Philip goff's
approach of pan psychism and stating
that biologies and principle physics
therefore let's skip biology and mess
around with the core Theory as soon as
particles Fields make up neurons
neurotransmitters
Etc from there on it may be better to
talk in biological terms instead of
skipping biology altogether in the
discussion so I think that I'm almost on
Phillips side here for this one so let
me explain what I mean by that
um certainly if the question was how do
we explain consciousness
then talking about biology and
Neuroscience and neurotransmitters is
absolutely necessary yes you should try
to do that you should that you cannot
ignore that okay but I'm not here to try
to explain Consciousness I'm here to
understand the fundamental laws of
physics and the nature of reality okay
so my only role in this discussion was
to talk about the plausibility of the
perspective that says in order to
explain Consciousness we must change the
laws of physics the currently known laws
of physics are not up to the task of
completely accounting for conscious
human experiences I think that that's
wrong and I think it's wrong in two ways
number one I think that the laws of
physics are perfectly up to that task
but number two people who don't think
that they are vastly underestimate the
difficulty of changing the laws of
physics and so I think that that is a
very tiny subset of these set of
interesting questions surrounding
Consciousness but it is a valid subset
that can skip this step of biology okay
so that discussion of whether or not we
need to change the laws of physics and
the Credence we should put on on
specified changes in laws of physics
becoming real because of Consciousness
issues is a perfectly legitimate set of
things to talk about even though it's
not anywhere close to Let's explain
Consciousness by itself
Simon Carter says do listener numbers
play a part in What topics you pick
you've mentioned before that the wine
episode was low on numbers so has that
stopped you from doing more episodes
around this you know no not really you
know I don't know exactly what my words
were but in fact for the audio podcast
listening audience which is the vast
majority there's a tiny number of people
who listen on YouTube even though
there's no video so there you go but
um the actual audio podcast numbers are
actually remarkably stable from episode
to episode there's a clearly a core
audience that listens to most episodes I
think that's just how it works there
will be some episodes if I do cosmology
or if I have something like Dan Dennett
on who's very well known then they will
get a little bit of extra listeners
Roger Penrose will get you extra
listeners
um and the sort of slightly more out
there topics will get a little bit fewer
but not enough to make a dramatic
difference I mean we're talking about
factors of the widest so there's a it's
more of an effect in the positive
direction in the negative Direction it's
more that a really really famous person
will get you more listeners than a weird
topic will get you fewer okay so I I'm
not really worried about having fewer
listeners with a weird topic and aside
from the the few very famous people that
I have and of course it's very famous by
mindscape listener standards so I
remember when I first joined wondery the
podcast Network and we were choosing
like what will be the first episode uh
to have for the first wondery episode
and I said well I do have Seth
MacFarlane coming on you know he's a
fairly well-known celebrity and they
said yes good let's do that and we did
that but you know as I tried to explain
to them Seth MacFarlane is far more well
known in the general public than let's
say Roger Penrose or Dan Dennis but he's
not going to get his good numbers in the
mindscape listenership as Roger Penrose
or damned and it will and he didn't I
mean he did well uh but it's not like
getting Carlo revelli on uh where you
get a lot of extra people listening so
um anyway within that uh list of people
I think that having a very famous person
will get you maybe twice the average
number whereas the decrement that you
get from the average for having a a less
well-known topic is maybe 10 below
average or 20 at most it's not worth
changing the topic
um distribution for that but also you
know I don't just think of individual
topics I try to make the blend of topics
thought fun and interesting and keep
people on their toes a little bit you
know I I know that lots of listeners
have their favorites and that's cool you
can have your favorites and basically no
one's forcing you to listen to every
episode you can listen to the ones you
like and that's great but I'd like to
you know slip in some episodes on topics
or with people who you would not have
anticipated and hopefully people will
listen to them and be happily surprised
or or they don't like it they try it and
don't like it that's a feature of trying
new things you know that's also
perfectly okay but part of my
self-appointed task is to bring in a
bunch of things maybe not the ones that
you would always expect so I continue to
want to do that
Sandro Stuckey says in your solo episode
on the Multiverse you mentioned that
desitter space is a maximum entropy
state that seems counter-intuitive How
could a highly symmetric vacuum State be
high entropy how could there be any
microstates if everything is smooth and
empty so there's two things going on
here two levels of answer to this one is
um think about it
high entropy states are always seemingly
smooth right if I have a box of gas if
all the gas is squeezed into a corner
that's low entropy the high entropy
configuration is the equilibrium where
the gas is smoothly distributed
throughout the Box what you're thinking
of is of course the microstates
corresponding to that macro state or in
maybe what you're thinking of is it the
microstates the individual atoms and
molecules are not perfectly smoothly
spread but that's partly a classical
kind of intuition that you're referring
to the decider state that we're
assigning a high entropy to is a quantum
mechanical state and the nature of a
thermal equilibrium Quantum state is a
little bit different the nature of a
high entropy Quantum State it's a little
bit different than the classical one
because there are wave functions not
individual positions and velocities of
particles
um the other thing going on at a
slightly more subtle level is its
quantum gravity
and we don't know the full theory of
quantum gravity so we don't know what
the microstates are
so when we say that the sitter space or
a black hole or whatever has a certain
entropy that's following Stephen
Hawking's ability to associate entropy
with the size of an event horizon and
it's a very robust calculation we can
you know it works as a thermodynamic
level you know let's go back to the mid
19th century we defined entropy clausius
Define the word long before boltzmann
came up with a definition of it in terms
of microstates right it was a
phenomenological thermodynamic quantity
that involved heat engines and things
like that our current understanding of
the entropy of a thing like the sitter
space or a black hole is similar to that
phenomological entropy we know the
macroscopic rules and we can assign an
entropy to it but we don't know the
complete microscopic Theory because we
haven't fully quantized gravity yet so
we have very strong confidence that the
entropy that we associate is the correct
one but I can't tell you what all the
microstates are that go into making up
that entropy if I did I would know a lot
more about quantum gravity than I do
so in other words the fact that decider
space has such a large entropy implies a
certain number of microstates but we
don't know physically how to really talk
about what those microstates are
okay Stephen says I have a noob question
about quantum mechanics all the strange
effects like entanglement or tunneling
how do they come about in nature where
in nature in our universe or in our
bodies are there ever particles isolated
enough so these effects don't go away by
the particles immediately interacting
with someone with something uh so
actually yeah it happens all the time
literally all the time so consider you
know a helium atom that has two
electrons two protons two neutrons and
also two electrons in the ground state
of the helium atom those two electrons
are very entangled with each other their
spins are entangled with each other
they're in what's called a singlet state
which is a superposition of spin up spin
down plus spin down spin up okay highly
entangled
um if you were to observe the spin of
one of those particles then you would
break the entanglement and you would not
you would you would excite the atom so
there'd no longer be in its ground state
so in that kind of slightly trivial
sense entanglement happens all the time
everywhere it's just that once you
separate the particles from each other
and measure them or do something with
them you break that entanglement so you
don't notice it all the time
Tyler ogarek says what are your thoughts
on Pascal's wager so Pascal's wager for
those of you don't know to the extent
that I remember it correctly and
probably not doing complete Justice to
Pascal but the basic idea is look maybe
God exists maybe God doesn't exist but
you know he lived Pascal lived in an
environment which was completely
Christian dominated so he said if God
exists I can you know believe in God and
go to church and be religious and maybe
I'll go to heaven
and if God exists and I don't believe in
God maybe I will go to hell
whereas if God doesn't exist it doesn't
matter whether I go to church or whether
I don't therefore all else being equal I
should go to church and believe in God
because I might get a reward from it
that's the wager okay this is complete
crazy talk nonsense this is very very
bad reasoning sorry because it would
make sense if you thought that the only
two choices were atheism or the
traditional Christian God right but of
course there are way more choices than
that maybe there's a God who respects
your decision if you are intellectually
honest and decide to be an atheist even
though you don't believe in God but this
particular God gets really annoyed at
hypocrisy and will send you to hell for
believing into him for bad reasons okay
um who knows maybe there's another God
maybe it's a Pantheon of gods you know
maybe it's something completely
animistic who has nothing to do with
Heaven or Hell who knows I don't know
and I think that Pascal's wager is a
very cheap way of ignoring a whole bunch
of possibilities unless you have some
probability distribution on these
possibilities you cannot accurately make
that wager as I'm sure Dr Pascal would
have been able to tell you if you've
been thinking carefully about
probabilities rather than about
Arguments for the existence of God
Emmett Francis says I'm currently
finishing up grad school and in the
process of interviewing for postdoc
positions in the area of computational
cell biophysics you've given some of
your thoughts on the play to postdocs
and past amas but I'm wondering if you
have any advice for me to make the most
of my experience as a postdoc you know I
only have very vague general purpose
advice I don't know anything about cell
biophysics
um the vague general purpose advice is
to keep in mind
that just like generals are always
planning for the last war
students and young scientists are always
being trained for their previous
position
so when you're an undergraduate you're
trained to solve problem sets right do
homework uh but no one cares about that
when you get to grad school when you get
to grad school the the thing is are and
then you're chosen for grad school and
the basis of how well you did on the
homework and then who cares about the
homework once you're there now you have
to do research so now your advisor gives
you research problems and your skill set
is following those research problems and
solving the puzzles that your advisor
sets to you great and then you're hired
for a postdoc and no one cares about
that skill set anymore because now you
have to come up with your own research
problems and of course that depends I
mean if you're in a lab maybe you're
still as a postdoc following the agenda
set by the uh Pi but in theoretical
physics you get to choose your own
research problems that's a whole new
skill set that you might not have had a
chance to develop while being an
undergraduate or even a graduate student
and then on the base of of your success
as a postdoc you're hired as a faculty
member and of course inventing your
research problems is still very
important but there's a whole new set of
skills that become important mentoring
and teaching and juggling administrative
duties and applying for Grants none of
which you've been trained for as a
postdoc so while you're a postdoc keep
in mind that your goal presumably is to
get hired as a faculty member at some
point or as a scientist in some
laboratory or something like that and
don't fall into the Trap of just doing
what you successfully did as a grad
student
do the things that will make you
employable and successful as a faculty
member and hopefully use those to have a
long and fruitful career okay so this
involves taking initiative this involves
not waiting around you know as as good
as many senior scientists are at being
mentors
many are not they're not trained to do
it and many kind of don't care about it
they want to do their own research
agenda and you have to sort of go along
with whatever lab you're in but also
look out for yourself do work that you
think is interesting and the rest of the
world thinks is interesting that work
might not be what you're trying to do as
a grad student think about what is going
to be the most fruitful Direction going
forward not what was the most fruitful
Direction 10 years ago when you got into
this game okay these are hard questions
to answer but this is what you got to do
as a postdoc if you want to keep going
forward
okay uh we're getting near the end here
don't panic I have a few more questions
Keith says in your 2019 fqxi talk on
causality in the era of time you briefly
contrasted the nuanced causality that
relies on the era of time with the
specific notion of causality and
relativity where it essentially just
means everything moves slower than the
speed of light
do you mind elaborating a tiny bit here
is a good way of putting it that the
arrow of time is something that
technically gets imported into
relativity
so no the era of time does not get
important to relativity but physicists
implicitly know that there is an arrow
of time when they ask questions so when
a physicist doing a relativist let's say
talks about causality and you don't need
this is not even General relatively
let's just do special relativities let's
do Maxwell's equations let's do
electromagnetism in flat minkowski space
time
what a physicist has in mind when they
talk about causality is imagine that you
have the electromagnetic field and you
poke it okay so you by hand put in some
influence that changes the
electromagnetic field at a point in
space time how do the consequences of
that poking Ripple out into the universe
and the answer is they Ripple out into
the future light cone of that point in
space-time well where did the word
future come from in that discussion the
answer is you put it in you assumed that
whatever happens when you actually poke
it like putting your finger in a pond in
the water the ripples actually do Ripple
out because of the thermodynamic Arrow
of time so there's an equally valid
solution to Maxwell's equation where the
only ripples focus in from the past on
that point in space time where you poked
it but no one cares about those
Solutions because they're not physically
relevant in the macroscopic world so the
relativists notion of causality uh is
ingrained in relativity there are light
cones but the way that it is used is
very very much colored by the fact that
physicists know there's narrow of time
and implicitly assume it in whatever
thought experiments they are carrying
out
David weich w-i-c-h says can deep
learning methods like deep neural
networks and Transformers really be
considered tools for scientific progress
when they're underlying models of data
generating process are not currently
interpretable or meaningful often they
don't even claim to be models or
representatives of the data generating
process well
they can be considered tools for
scientific progress you know my analogy
that I like to use which is only
is incomplete it's an inadequate analogy
as all analogies are but I like to think
of deep learning as sort of Tico brahee
the famous astronomer right Tico you
know was one of the first to use
telescopes and uh to make systematic
astronomical observations or no way
actually sorry he didn't use telescopes
uh he used surveying instruments but he
did very precise uh
I guess astrometric observations of the
sky telescopes were not widespread at
the time but he had an observatory and
what he would do is just look at the sky
and Survey it so where are the planets
as a function of Time how do they move
through the sky and things like that
finding comets what have you big data by
the standards of the time right he
collected a lot of data he had wealthy
patrons who helped him support his habit
of collecting a lot of data and what did
he do with the data you know nothing
very inspiring he and he had a model of
the solar system that wasn't very
accurate or anything like that
but he didn't really contribute on the
theoretical level to a vast Improvement
in understanding his student Kepler did
Kepler was the one who realized that
from Tico's data you could infer that
the easiest explanation of what the
planets are doing is that they're moving
in the lipses not in circles with
epicycles like Tico's model did as well
as ptolemyin and Copernicus and so forth
and so Kepler actually had laws right
Kepler's laws and that was a true
scientific understanding so true
scientific understanding is not just a
correlation between bits of data that
you can discover by doing a deep
learning algorithm it's a principle it's
an equation it's a relationship that you
understand why it is like that in the
implications of it so you know if you
had a deep learning algorithm in in
Tico's time maybe you could have plotted
out the Motions of the planets but if
you'd asked okay now I have a
hypothetical new plan it how will it
move it would have no idea because all
it has done is looked at the other
planets whereas with Kepler's laws you
can have a prediction for how other
planets are going to behave and then
Newton's laws were even better because
they could talk about the perturbations
on those orbits from other planets so
the true scientific understanding is not
just fitting curves with data but
getting the data and finding what the
curves are is a crucial part of it so I
have no trouble believing that deep
learning will play a huge role in the
advancement of scientific progress but
it's not the entire story
Ube Kune says is it possible that there
is a CO another coexisting world made up
of Dark Matter within our universe Dark
Matter planets Dark Matter life forms
Dark Matter spacecraft made by those
life forms Etc
um so the short answer is probably not
it's very very unlikely and the reason
why is because dark matter is dark and
that doesn't just mean that it doesn't
interact with light it doesn't interact
with anything like light or at least not
very strongly you know one of my
favorite personal papers I've ever
written was on the possibility of dark
electromagnetism we proposed that uh
Dark Matter particles could be charged
under a kind of electromagnetism but
that only talked to Dark Matter not to
ordinary matter and you can do that if
the force is a little bit weaker than
ordinary electromagnetism and the Dark
Matter particles are sufficiently heavy
if they're if they're light like
electrons then you would have noticed
this a long time ago but if they're
heavy enough then they're dilute enough
in the universe that the existence of
this extra dark electromagnetism isn't
that noticeable
but in order to build
stars and planets and spacecraft you
need the Dark Matter particles to be
able to interact with each other and
dissipate fairly effectively and dark
matter doesn't do that you know we can
map out where the dark matter is and
it's not in planets and stars it's more
or less diffusely spread out through the
universe so the simplest ideas that dark
matter is just no interactions at all
and there are pretty good limits on how
strong any possible interactions can be
that makes it very very difficult to
imagine dark atoms and so forth but it's
not impossible so in fact in our the end
of our paper on dark electromagnetism we
said you know you could imagine dark
atoms and then what happens in that case
is as long as the purported dark atom is
made of two heavy particles like real
atoms are made of heavy particles like
protons and neutrons also light
particles like electrons but if the dark
matter both positively charged and
negatively charged particles are both
heavy
then you can get away with it
then they form a dark atom that is
basically like a neutral particle okay
even though there is an electromagnetic
force it's it's more or less all
invisible to you because everything's
neutral and so my new colleague here
David Kaplan at Johns Hopkins he and his
collaborators wrote some papers on dark
atoms and and things like that
um it's very interesting stuff and I I
still think that the answer is you can't
go so far as to get dark planets in
spacecraft but it is an interesting
intellectual exercise to imagine how far
you can go there's almost no reason to
expect that that is what dark matter is
like but uh you can at least ask the
question
okay the last question is from Sheldon's
silly man that might not be this
person's real name
but the question is I'm curious about
the makeup of your mindscape podcast
audience what percentage are students
science hobbyists other scientists Etc
I'm hopeful that a good portion of your
audience is Young and excited for the
potential discoveries we all can make uh
yeah I don't know it's a very good
question I left it as a last question
here because you know I I'd like to
think also that the audience is diverse
in many ways age gender distribution uh
geographically but you know
realistically I expect that the United
States and other English-speaking
countries are overrepresented
um that science curious people are
overrepresented Etc
um but otherwise I don't know I don't
know what the age distribution is at all
I'd like to think there's lots of young
people listening to the podcast but I
really don't know maybe like there's an
age sweet spot for podcast listeners
that I don't know about and maybe people
who are older than that and younger than
that don't listen not really sure about
that I mean maybe video podcasts are
already old-fashioned for teenagers and
they're on to something else so I don't
know but I do know that you know so even
though I don't have an accurate
representative sample
I do know that I have you know
interacted either through patreon or
through Twitter or even in person with a
bunch of people from all sorts of
different backgrounds ages uh interests
things like that so I'm very happy uh
the diversity that there is there in the
mindscape audience and once again
I'm happy to all the patreon supporters
for keeping the podcast going uh keeping
these amas A's going you ask great
questions during the amas I'm as I
always say I'm going to keep saying it
so get used to it I'm sad I can't answer
all the questions they're all worth
answering I depict some that I thought
were the most uh I could say something
about or just wanted to talk about
um but they're all good keep asking them
thank you for the support of mindscape
uh here's to another several wonderful
years of more podcast episodes in the
future
[Music]